Ladies and Gentlemen,
day 27.
Is that what it is,
Brian?
Uh,
yeah.
Week 27 or podcast 27,
right?
We did two in a week once.
That was a crazy week.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome once again to the a weekly
Ustream podcast really has been fucking
weekly man.
I say it's 29.
We're waiting.
Late podcast 29.
It's amazing that we kept kept with it
for this long and it's also amazing that
I never did anything like this before.
It is,
you know,
it takes me so long to get into a groove
with anything.
It took me so long to accept like email
lists and my space and all that shit.
Like for the longest time I was like,
I don't want to get involved in
promoting myself.
Fuck that,
you know,
fuck advertising shells.
Just get on the radio and just do it
like normal.
But then you see all these other dudes
that are doing it that way and they're
doing so well with it.
What happened to your shit?
I think my space is the first one that
actually went crazy like that made you
realize the power of the Internet.
Like fleshlight.
Yeah.
Well the,
my space days,
that was the comedy store days and we
were using the uh,
when we were using the mice brains,
fucking comedy store was sold out like
every weekend and it was just because of
my space,
which didn't know before then man,
you could never have the,
they would have to drive by and just
know that you're there because of the
billboard or just know that you're there
because of word of mouth,
but you know,
we could throw it up on my space and it
was nothing now or a school yard of
paper.
Boys going,
my space is a fucking dinosaur.
You know,
why?
Because my space didn't adapt.
I logged in last night,
first time and I think like two months
check went through three or four pages
of people that were fake.
People asking me to talk and stuff like
that.
One new person going,
hey dude,
here's my facebook page.
Add me every now and then I'll go and
read a little bit of the fan mail,
but it's just not worth it.
It's just a,
it's a graveyard.
It's like,
you know,
it's going to turn noble after the blast
and like talking to the people that are
still there.
Like,
God,
man,
get Outta here.
Why did you here?
Using my space for Patton.
Oswald used my place still though.
There's this gentleman before we get
going.
Her podcast is sponsored by the
fleshlight I kinda show every week.
I don't know if that's like,
I feel like I at Barker's beauties,
I'm supposed to be demonstrating the
product,
but uh,
it's what it is,
is basically a masturbation tool if you
haven't used it for a.
We talk about it every week to fucking
fantastic as far as beating off.
If you beat off and I know you do,
it's way better than just regular
beating off.
So not that much money.
How much is money as across Brian?
It's like,
I don't know,
but you get 15 percent off your if you
go on your way.
I don't know how much at all.
I think it's like $69.
Fifty $9.
Seventy $9.
I did your tip though,
uh,
this week and it's kind of,
of course a crazy thing happened.
Every time I do anything with a
flashlight,
something crazy warm water thing.
No,
I put it outside and uh,
they let it heat up.
Of course,
my landlords often go out in the back to
smoke and then because they work above
me and they see this rubber pussy out in
the sun,
they saw it out in the sun.
Oh my God.
Because when I went to pick it up,
they were sitting out there.
If you go to the fleshlight says this
website contains explicit adult
material.
What,
how crazy is it that you go to a website
that has rubber poseys and they have
this crazy fucking warning you're about
to see explicit adult material.
I mean,
do they have porn on their site?
Okay.
They have a guy and not even nudity.
Those girls have clothes on.
There was a guy in the girl in bed,
but the girl had a bra and panties on.
And uh,
if you're looking at all of these
flashlights,
man,
it's like,
okay,
yeah,
it's rubber body part.
Is that really something you need to
have a little warning click through.
You go to those sites,
receive violence,
you know,
you don't see shit like that,
but why can you just walk into a hustler
store without them stopping and telling
you the same thing?
Something,
a lot of hustlers tours out there in the
world is there and their stories just
like it,
like porn stores,
if that isn't one of those weird things
when we go on the road and we see these,
uh,
these fucking towns like,
you know,
like if you go to like a,
what's a good example of that?
A bunch of them,
a Youngstown,
Ohio,
I was doing chosen Youngstown,
Ohio and it's like there's a bunch of
those little sad 24 hour neon lit adult
shops and that's just,
that's just people that's just like
reluctant body maintenance,
like poor sad fucks.
And those places just wandering around,
looking depressed,
pushing those beads apart.
It's like,
why do they have to use beads?
Beads make fucking noise right?
When you push those beads apart and they
click and you go back into the dirty,
dirty area and see all the cock suck and
videos and shit.
I used to work at a video store that had
an adult room and it was open 24 hours a
day and it was kinda cool because he'd
walk somebody to be walking up like a
hot chick and you're like,
please let them go into the adult room,
you know,
of course they just walk up and go,
where's he at?
Designing women season two,
you know,
or something.
The craziest thing happened is an old
teacher of mine,
first grade teacher went in there,
a woman and got porn and I could only
hope it was for like a party.
Saw her.
Yeah,
she,
I waited on her.
She'd probably didn't recognize me
because I'm,
you know,
I was like 20 and she was like,
uh,
you know,
older lady.
So this is your first grade teacher,
first grade teacher.
First grade is what?
Seven,
six,
six.
I don't know,
something like that.
And because I rang her up,
I also saw her last name was ms dot blah
blah blah.
And I'm like,
oh,
that's totally her.
Anyway,
she got the uh,
that's when I found out that a semester
still alone did a porn called the
Italian stallion and that's what she had
got.
So I don't think that was a real porn
though.
I think it was one of those like
showtime three in the morning,
porns.
Right.
So I think that I,
uh,
I thought like,
oh,
this is for a gag this for a party.
I accept this.
But see,
I could also see her whole history and
it was like big black Dick Five,
you know,
it was only rented porn.
Sixty eight 70 maybe she was 70.
That pitches of freak.
That's crazy.
Just keeping it alive,
Huh?
Yeah.
Who.
So you don't think that Italian stallion
was a report?
I don't know.
I never watched it talking out of my
ass,
but I'm pretty sure it wasn't.
I'm pretty sure it was like some fake
3:00
in the morning.
Shit,
we had the porn side.
I saw a chick that I,
I used to date in one of those fake 3:00
in the morning porns where a dude is
fake bone in her,
so I have to do,
it was just a little too low,
right?
Like she was like a pie a little too
high and he was like,
you tell her their groin isn't really
touching one of those,
you know,
and it was really freaky.
I was by myself and I slipped through
the channels and it's like,
Whoa,
here's,
here's a person that,
you know,
I hadn't seen her in years is a long
time ago.
So it was like I dated her over,
you know,
12 years ago,
13,
14 years ago.
Even.
So seeing her,
it was like,
wow,
this is kind of strange.
Like I'm watching some of that I used to
know and then they're fucking in a movie
even though it's not real,
you know?
What do you think is like,
if you like your high school sweetheart
turns into like Sasha grey or something
like that?
I could tell you what it's like,
I know what it's like.
I fucking,
it's weird,
man.
I don't even like thinking about it.
No,
no,
no.
You don't know what it's like because in
your situation,
the person that,
if any person we're talking about is an
actual real person,
right?
These are people that you met when you
knew that they already did that thing.
Right.
It's a big thing to have a girl have it
be your girlfriend.
This is my girl,
my check,
and then there's some freaking brute
just doggy style on her and sweating and
spitting on her and shit.
You fucking bitch.
You like that?
And you're like,
Whoa,
that guy's fucking the shit out of my ex
girlfriend.
Yeah.
Especially real porn.
I have never found like old porn of like
a girl I've dated.
Have you ever done that?
Like you're going through their old
photos and they go,
well,
I'm not a snoopy motherfuckers.
I mean,
have you ever done that?
Like were like they're going through
photos,
like,
oh,
this is my old boyfriend.
Oh Dope.
You don't want to see this photo.
And then like,
no,
but I do always get sad when girls try
to make me jealous like using.
I've always been sad like my whole life,
I've always thought that was one of the
weakest things ever.
When someone you can tell,
the only reason why they're bringing
this up or they're talking about the
racks is to try to fuck with your head.
Like it never works.
All of that.
It makes you feel uncomfortable.
But the uncomfort that I feel is,
oh,
you're not as cool as I thought you
were.
And Yeah,
now you're creepy and you're trying to
fuck with me and okay,
can I talk you out of this?
Can I tell you that this is not
necessary?
And we're just,
you know,
two people that are enjoying each
other's company,
getting to know each other.
You know,
we don't have to play these stupid games
that we've already played in the past.
We should all learn,
right?
I played some stupid games and it was a
little kid then I had to learn that
they're dumb.
So when someone doesn't know the games
like that are dumb,
like jealousy games from like fucking
really,
you know,
come on man,
what am I fucking child?
Cut The shit so another guy fucked you.
You're crazy.
Get out of here.
I couldn't.
I can't believe it.
You're hot and you're 26 and another guy
is fucked you already.
Jesus Christ.
Was this recent?
Was this with the pitches probably
sucking somebody's dick an hour before
she picked you up.
You know,
she's fucking crazy.
It makes me wonder if that should ever
go away because it doesn't seem like it
is like my mom get in a fight with her
boyfriend and you just do stupid shit
like that goes away for sure.
It goes away and went with maturity.
Everything evolves.
It's the problem is when people get,
they go from one shit relationship to
the next shit relationship and they
never get traction as a human being.
Never get traction and never realized.
And if you have shit friends on top of
that,
which a lot of girls do,
man,
especially pretty girls,
a lot of pretty girls.
Their friends be hating.
You know?
It's tough man because for them it's
like you're out with a pretty girl.
If you're a girl and you're out with a
pretty girl,
no one is going to pay attention to you.
Everyone's going to pay any attention to
her,
and she didn't even do anything to
deserve this.
She was just born this way and you're so
much funnier and so much cooler and
you'd be so much pedal girlfriend and
you will get crazy for that bitch and
you'll try to trip her up.
You'll want her to fail.
You will hope she falls and breaks her
fucking nose.
You know,
like literally like you're tired.
She's stealing from you.
She stealing mail attention from you.
You know?
That's how a lot of chicks feel about
hot chicks,
man.
They don't like it.
So anything like that,
man,
if,
if that's your situation,
if you're around people like that or do
shit to you and you've around ex
boyfriends were,
do she,
you,
you just,
you can get into a bad grind where you
just automatically get douchey first
because you think they're going to get
douchey first and you want to get the
upper hand.
You know,
you ever getting those relationships,
we can tell that someone's fucking with
you just to get the upper hand and
expecting more and worse is when you go
with it.
Just to see where it goes.
The worst for me is if I get involved in
it and I haven't been working out,
especially when I was younger.
Dude,
when I was younger,
I did not have such a good judgment and
I still don't sometimes about when to
argue and went to the school without
fuck.
Am I arguing over,
back down.
I just argued automatically.
I'm like,
you're not going to stop me from
arguing,
fuck you,
and it would just turn ugly every time.
Every time I got an argument with
somebody,
it would turn ugly,
but as I got older,
you know any,
any kind of relationship like that when
shit comes up now,
I just.
I tried very,
very hard now to just look at it and go,
what is the purpose of all this?
What or who gives a shit?
If you're right,
who gives a shit?
If you're wrong,
who gets,
here's what I want.
I want to be around people that I enjoy
talking to and I know there can't really
be this many problems that we fight all
the time.
If there's this many problems that we
fight all the time,
where's that coming from?
That's got to be a personality thing
because I don't have that many problems
in my life.
My Life's pretty smooth.
Most of the people in my life were very
nice.
Most of the people in my life,
we enjoy each other's company.
The very few.
I mean everybody has like here and
there.
There'll be issues with any human being
where someone sees something totally
differently,
but you can talk it through and if
you're really good friends,
you're work it out and everything's cool
and nobody ever gets ugly,
you know?
But the real key man is finding other
people that go along with that because
as soon as you go with someone who's
used to do shit and is used to insulting
you and is used to playing games,
as soon as you go
into that and dive into that world,
man,
you're fucked.
No progress,
no fun,
and it's so hard to get at it,
so then once you get out of it,
you're so sad because he got out of it.
You have to get back in.
It's his because he felt so sad for you.
Getting out of that being alone man,
when you just got out of a relationship
and then all of a sudden you're alone
and lonely.
Those are the darkest empty.
It's hollow moments.
As an adult human being that feelings a
terrible,
terrible feeling.
Most people just aren't equipped to
understand rationally what's really
going on,
like why are you so upset?
How much of this is just evolutionary?
How much is this?
It's been designed into the whole human
mechanism too dreadful to feel dreadful.
Every time you're left alone to feel
terrible,
every time you're rejected,
you're being rejected by someone you
don't even know is brutally painful.
Why is that?
Why is?
Why would you even care if it was a dude
who didn't like you?
If you had no desire to fuck that
person?
If you just came up to a dude,
that dude was like,
look at you.
You don't even good looking.
You'd be like,
what the fuck you faggot.
You wouldn't care at all.
It wouldn't change your opinion of
yourself at all,
but when a chick does it to,
it's like devastating.
Totally.
Especially if it's a chick that you're
attracted to,
but it's all evolution.
It's all set up that way to try to get
you to be as attractive as possible and
to make very stringent standards that
what people find and don't find a
traction attractive.
It's to make you operate at a higher
level.
I think it's all just designed to make
you work harder as a human being to
become more impressive as a mate and in
doing so and it becoming more impressive
as a mate,
you get to contribute more to society.
You'll create more energy.
You'll create more money.
You'll create more whatever you do,
whether you.
If you don't,
you know your technology,
you'll innovate more.
If you're an art,
you're producing more art.
You want to prove your worth and so
that,
that craziness like allows people to
shine.
You know,
I can't find that girl though.
You know I can't.
I can't find that partner,
whereas on the same level as me,
it seems like they,
they,
uh,
always act like the same level,
but then once you get into it,
they're just,
they were just like kind of mimicking
what they thought that that level is
that
also that they want you to be something
that you're not,
it's,
you know,
they want you to be a not even a real
person,
you know,
they have a lot of people have an idea
in their head that's really almost kind
of based on movies,
you know.
Ah,
what was it like like before the 18
hundreds based on movies?
Totally better.
Yeah.
To everybody.
But that's how it is.
You know,
you see movies and everything works out
fucking awesome in the movies and you
go,
well,
that's what life is like,
right?
Life is like this.
It's,
this is my model of life.
Sandra bullock movies and you get,
you get trapped in your head thinking,
well maybe this isn't.
Maybe he's not the one,
you know,
maybe there is another one.
Like God damn,
what is this crazy?
Well,
what about you?
Are you the one he probably not the one,
you know,
it might,
it might be,
you know,
the fucking problem might be you over
and over again with everybody.
It's kind of like,
like the fight club or relationship
where the whole time it actually is you.
Well Dude,
I've been that guy.
I've totally been that
guy,
but start arguments,
relationships for no reason just because
I was frustrated with my own life.
Especially when I was really young.
I was 20 when I was like 20 and 21.
Oh,
it starts stupid arguments with girls.
I was dating over nothing but it wasn't
really them.
That was the problem.
It was really me.
It was really me like being frustrated
all the time with my life and trying to
like being like hyper ambitious and
trying to like get ahead in my life but
really terrified that I was going to be
a loser.
So I would always be like under stress
and if anything annoys me about a check,
I would like been like,
why do you even talk like that?
Like what?
Meanwhile,
that's such a douchey thing to do,
to take your frustrations out on someone
else,
but when you're doing it,
when it's,
when you're wrapped up in it,
man,
especially if that's like everyone in
your family,
that's everyone your friends with,
you know,
that's the only way you know it takes a
long time to learn,
to not communicate shitty to people.
If you're stuck and like a shitty
communication pattern,
fuck,
that's hard to snap out of that.
Very hard,
very hard to recognize how other people
are seeing you.
Like so many people don't think that
they come off as assholes.
They think they're just playing around
and everybody's like,
oh,
this guy's such a Douche.
Get him away from me.
It's like,
fuck.
You can't take a joke.
It's not a joke of.
I don't think it's funny.
You know,
it's not a joke if no one else is
laughing,
but you.
That's not a joke.
That's you being a douchebag and
laughing about being a Douche bag.
What the fuck,
Brian,
how do we fix the world?
Old?
Definitely not alcohol because it seems
like more in the end I've fixed your
vegas really taught me a lot about
alcohol,
you know,
like just just seeing people on alcohol
is just weird.
It does terrible things for your
judgment.
I enjoyed myself so much more.
Saturday night I had water.
I drank water all night.
We went to that party,
smoked a little weed.
It was fun.
You know,
the problem with alcohol is everybody
else else's drinking too and you wind up
getting stupid conversations over
nothing.
It.
We,
we got to hang out with Doug Benson and
I've never really even talked to him
before.
You know,
I've seen him a couple times,
but hanging out with Doug Benson stone
with a couple of beers in us,
I fucking had dance off with him for
what?
Two hours,
me and him,
me and him were dancing.
I never,
he's a good dude.
We really enjoyed hanging out with.
He's a real good dude.
He,
I,
I've never really.
I've done his podcast before.
You know,
I've seen them like here and there clubs
and talked to them every now and then.
But this is the most time I ever spent
with them by far.
We went to dinner with them and talk to
them a lot.
Who's cool man,
really cool guy.
And I always questioned how much he
really enjoyed pot and I will never
questioned his pot likeness again.
He fucking really questioned it.
That's so funny that stoners are always
doing that.
Legit.
Why?
And I've totally felt for something that
happens to you every day,
almost it's where you go up to him like,
dude,
come on,
smoke weed.
I smoke a joint.
And he was just like,
no.
But I mean it's also like we're hanging
out with other comics and stuff so it's
a little different.
But still that happens to me.
How often?
Everyday.
Every time we're out at a club,
it seems like
every time.
Everywhere.
And you're like,
you don't know who these people are.
Like they could have crazy shit in
there.
We'd
get high on acid.
I'm not going to drive home.
And you know the Double Lane,
double rainbow look up double rainbow on
Youtube.
No,
I don't want to see the bank.
Oh No,
no,
I just bought a two months so I even
watched the whole video.
I watched like half of the video and I
shut it off.
I get it,
I get it.
He's freaking out over rainbow.
The remix they did that robot voice,
what you know with the voice and the
edit it real quick.
Kind of like of and they edit like Tim
and Eric style,
that auto tune shit.
Catch on.
What the fuck happened?
I got paint on my iphone to you.
Do you like that stuff?
It's kind of cool.
Just like singing something that you
thought of and then just changing the
lyrics and next thing you know you can
actually make it into a real song.
Like even if it's like you're going to
hurt or you know that song,
that drake song,
it's over.
Does he use that Shit autotune?
Because I kinda liked that song.
I think everyone uses audit trail in the
pop industry right now.
The pump industry,
like Lindsay Lohan should be using pot.
The pato to.
Lindsay's going to do some time now.
Huh?
If you don't know ladies gentlemen.
Brian says,
where'd you read this off of?
I watched it live on cbs life,
you know,
they put it on video,
live courtroom.
She's going to do 90 days in jail.
That is just to turn herself in two
weeks unless she suicides,
but she still has to wear the bracelet
so she can't drink every day and they
made it like a big deal.
Like we want to switch to a blood,
a blood thing instead of,
you know,
the scram and the reason why she wants
to do that because if you drink alcohol
at midnight,
like by 4:00
AM,
it's not in your blood anymore.
And that's why Lindsay wants to do that.
So it's so funny that the thing that
really got to me was where they judge,
like heard Lindsey crying and stuff and
the judge finally goes,
all right,
you did live here,
you live here,
you lied here.
Next case you live here,
you live here.
You went through like,
like four cases of like seven.
I didn't know if Lockton,
someone up in jail is like the best way
to deal with this,
but this should all be a bright example
to people.
Uh,
really,
uh,
a prominent example to people.
How you shouldn't make your fucking kids
famous.
How many kids have to become incredibly
fucked up from being famous child actors
before we look at it and go,
this is nuts.
There's no way you should be doing that
to a child.
There's no way you should be developing
as a human being.
Getting your shit together,
getting your ego together is hard enough
as it is.
But to have that developing,
getting your shit together and then mix
it with fame.
God,
can you imagine 10 years from now,
will Smith's kids going to jump on your
back and slice or next,
oh,
he's probably just going to be sad or
no,
it's fine.
Well,
is a really brilliant guy.
He's a very smart guy.
He might figure out a way to raise his
kid correctly through this,
but what an incredible fucking chore.
What an incredible responsibility and
the amount of pressure you put on the
kid because kids,
you know,
they get spoiled so easy.
Their perspective get fucked up
so quickly.
They haven't really developed character.
They tend to have a kid really be in a
position where he never really has to
overcome the same adversity of the rest
of us have.
He just doesn't have the opportunity to
develop the character that the rest of
us are going to have.
The regular people that have to go
through life and make their way as an
adult and evolve as an adult and be an
adult without money.
Where you're in a situation where you're
like,
wow,
I've got to figure out a way to get
through this and to not have any fame
whatsoever.
You know,
have to get by on your personality
instead of get by on the fact that
you're famous when you were six.
I heard that,
that,
that first eight years of your life,
you learn 88 percent of what makes you
who you are today.
Like the things like from from walking
all the way to how you react to certain
things and the rest is what you have to
deal with,
like your ram on those.
Right?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I've read some stuff about up to two
years old.
I didn't read up to eight,
but it makes sense.
I mean a lot of who you are as a human
being is based on what kind of input you
got when your mind was developing.
It only makes sense.
Your mind is going to prepare for a
certain world,
you know,
they say that babies born into in into
really high stress violent families
where there's a lot of shouting and
yelling and you know,
too many people,
like if you're in a really bad
neighborhood and you know too many
people in your house and there's a lot
of stress all the time.
People,
babies born literally are wired
different than babies that are born into
calm households and babies that are born
into calm households.
Like the less stress you have,
the more chilled out the baby can be.
But if you have like a really,
really tense mom,
that kid's going to come out just ready
to snap.
That kid's going to come out recognizing
danger.
I had this long talk on a plane with
Michael Irvin.
Michael Irvin was on a plane to
Australia.
We were all going to the UFC.
He was going there to do some football
thing with Russell Russell Crowe and I
had met him because I did a best damn
sports show period and he was on it and
he's a real cool guy,
man.
And very down to Earth normal dude.
And so he and I were talking and we're
just talking about kids getting involved
in martial arts and kids getting
involved in sports.
And he was talking about like what he
was like when he was young that,
you know,
he's trying to like teach kids,
about controlling themselves,
keep teach kids about keeping their shit
together.
And this was right after that dude that,
I don't remember the football player,
but he was chasing after his girlfriend.
He jumped in the back of a truck and he
fell out and died.
I remember that.
I don't remember the guy's name.
Yeah,
he was talking about that guy that,
that guy that,
that was not thinking.
He was just reacting like you don't
think you don't do shit like that when
you're thinking,
but these guys aren't thinking they just
react and that he's trying to teach them
how to like put some steps in there to
like consider things before you act and,
and recognize that there's a reason why
you are so quick to behave like that and
that these people,
these reckless type people are the ones
who are always involved in like really
strong competitive athletics like
fighting and men football and shit like
that because they're,
they're so much more quick to react.
There's so much more explosive that a
lot of it is just stress based me to.
So many fighters are born from shitty
households.
So many.
Yeah.
I mean it's somehow a prerequisite.
There's guys from strong families that
still are great fighters because they
just accept that,
you know,
they just love the challenge.
Like George St Pierre is a perfect
example of that.
Very close with his dad,
but a lot of guys come from fucking
broken homes,
man,
and there's a,
there's something in that.
There's something in that.
The fury is just a little more intense
from a dude who grows up without a dad
or dude to grows up in like a real
shitty situation.
You know?
It's fucking crazy,
man.
When he really stopped to think about
it,
it's crazy that anybody would want their
kid to be famous.
The Lindsay Lohan thing,
this should be the last draw.
Well,
there shouldn't be some condo laws about
it.
Definitely,
but I think most of the people that have
their kids,
it's because they're,
they're broken dreams and they're using
their kids,
you know,
to.
Do you think that's it?
It was just a lack of awareness there.
Lack,
lack of real,
real consideration.
You see?
Nobody thinks it's an offensive thing.
Like,
you know,
if you,
if you tell them,
you know,
all my daughter's a acting,
she's in a commercial.
They go,
Oh,
good for you.
Nobody ever goes,
wow,
what are you doing?
Like why are you putting your kid on tv?
Nobody.
Nobody ever says that.
Nobody ever says it like,
Whoa,
you're putting,
you're going to fuck your kid up.
You're going to get your kid famous.
You know what the odds are?
If you've got your kid famous,
what are the odds of your kids going to
grow up and be a mess?
So like 90 percent.
Why would you ever.
I mean,
yeah,
there's a few that get through it and
they're okay that Jodie foster's of the
world that seemed to be adjusted,
but they're fucking rare.
Dude,
what are you making it?
Why the fuck is that?
Oh,
I forgot to ask video.
Just making.
He forgot to,
to really forget that did I really did
something so fucking silly.
He made the lesbian lick the hand thing.
Yeah,
I mean what the fuck man you to develop
and to think that you're special right
from the beginning.
I mean,
Lindsay Lohan was famous from.
She was one of those Disney hookers,
right?
So many Disney hookers there is.
They breed them.
They make these little hot little
hookers.
Let's count them off.
Who are the Disney hookers?
Christy,
Christina Aguilera.
She had Disney made it through
timberlake.
Was He cool?
He's got it together.
Dude.
That dude's got it totally down.
He really?
Yeah.
That's super six festival guy.
He's still super successful too though.
There's never a drop off.
Drop off.
It's all right,
Carrie.
Whatever.
When they drop off,
that's when they get nuts.
Right?
Right.
It's hard to rebound and people want to
see how far you fall and crash.
So they kind of support.
You're dropping,
right.
You know,
they turn their energy on while he's
really failing.
You have to hit rock bottom and then
they'll let you come back up again.
You know,
you have to Britney Spears that you have
to fucking just ride that boat.
Run into the rocks now.
Do you think Brittany has snapped back
or do you think she has just a new
person that protects their nonstop,
you know,
like I am hired to make sure you don't
fuck up ever again.
You don't fix that kind of crazy.
You don't fix it.
That shit is not fixable.
That's crazy to the bones,
man.
Just,
you know,
she's,
she's fucking nuts.
They're not fixing anything.
That's a real simple case to me.
Case closed.
They just,
they're just handling her.
Are they married?
Brian Austin.
Green.
The fuck happened.
Oh,
what's her face?
Megan Fox.
You think she's.
She's Wacky to Brian.
Austin Green.
Actually,
I don't tell you young.
Right?
Was She?
When she got famous?
She probably is a really cool chick if
she met and married Brian Austin Green.
Well,
yeah.
Right.
Think about that.
It's not even right.
Who's not even working anymore?
Chick ever either.
That uh,
Brian Austin Green.
It's like a pimp of unimaginable.
We partially a pimp.
He doesn't have his name tattooed on
her.
Yeah,
I say he's a pimp.
Daddy has to be a.
well you can hate all you want about
anybody.
Can you know you people out there you
want to hate?
What if that was you?
I don't know.
It's just if you're at the peach pit,
which guy would you choose?
You know,
peach pit.
The list.
You have to take it to some dark,
dark place.
This Brian Austin Green fellow.
Isn't he like a rapper now?
Doesn't need wrap.
Does he really?
It doesn't mean.
I don't know.
I didn't think he did A.
I think we need to find out right now.
This is the beautiful.
This is beautiful.
What a beautiful time to be alive and
the Internet.
If you have a question,
he just throw that pitch into google.
So simple.
Brian Austin,
green wrapping.
We are about to find out,
ladies and gentlemen,
we don't have to go to the fucking
library.
We don't have to go to a college and
meet some experts.
Have Brian?
I said,
okay.
That was on TV.
That wasn't.
No.
See,
that's what I think it is.
I think it's.
I think it's just a like he had to go
into his wiki.
I see what the moment and rap history
around the same time,
his character,
David silver,
started wrapping his lyrical stylings.
You are so precious to me and my
precious to you.
The answer Brian is yes.
That was so pointless.
I missed the very beginning of it,
but still he didn't have his rapping
mean it had some of his lyrics.
I think that they're just saying that he
was a rapper,
but it was whack,
but we can't play it because they don't
have to pay him or something.
Oh really?
You know,
something like that [inaudible] that was
on vh one.
Well,
they,
they were also saying that he's wack
mean they quoted his lyrics.
That's pretty wack.
It sucks.
That's just like those lyrics were so
whack.
Like you don't even have to pass a
judgment on them.
You just playing for people and raise
your eyebrows and go.
So it gives you that movie with Jesus
camp.
Uh,
yeah.
Crazy,
crazy fucking moving.
And the best part about the movies,
they didn't cast any judgment.
They just showed you these nutty
motherfuckers that are out there raising
kids to be Christian jihadists,
you know that you don't have to,
you don't have to cast anything and the
people are so nutty that they'll approve
it.
You could show them the fucking video
and they would,
they would,
they would say,
Yep,
that's our,
that's our message.
You got our message down,
sir.
That's a good documentary.
Meanwhile,
anybody who saw that thing,
it was like a fucking horror movie
taking little kids and the best part is
when they make them talk in tongues.
Did you see that part?
They would say everybody now talking
tons.
So the kids would go Sharmila,
Mola,
mark.
Hello,
hello.
Am I god talking through them in
tongues?
It's hilarious.
They're five years old,
man,
five years old.
It's nonsense.
They love nonsense.
Five years old.
Love to talk.
Nonsense.
All five-year-old kids do.
So you give them like a time of the day
at school.
Our kids time to go.
Nonsense.
So they just go through fantasy and they
tuck it in.
This made up language and it's obviously
not a fucking language because you're
not saying anything.
You.
I can tell when I'm listening to someone
talk,
even if they have a foreign language,
I can tell if it's a real language.
You know,
you hear someone talking in like in
Chinese,
like they're saying a bunch of crazy
shit,
but there is a flow to it where you
know,
they're not seeing the same sounds over
and over and over and over again.
Which is what you do because you have to
invent all these sounds on the fly.
If you're making a fake language,
like to have them very to the point
where it looks like it's like an actual
like language that's difficult.
So you start going,
which is what they all do.
They're all uncreative fucks and they're
talking in tongues and they're just
making nonsense noises.
That's all they're doing,
man.
And they're getting little kids to do
this shit and they're telling these kids
that,
you know,
you know your,
your warriors for Christ and there this
woman,
it was comparing them to how,
you know Hamas and all these terrorist
organizations raised little jihadists.
She was literally comparing them.
She's comparing them like,
why don't we do that with Christianity?
Like this would be a good thing.
The reason why these people are willing
to blow themselves up.
It's because they indoctrinated them
into the world of radical Islam.
We can do the same thing but for good.
She's like,
but we're good.
Not seeing the.
The irony,
you know,
in the brainwashing kids she's talking
to,
well,
they're getting brainwashed with the
wrong thing,
but if we brainwash our kids with the
truth and Jesus and like,
Whoa,
Jerell how to raise kids.
I had two guys a knock on my door today
that we're both my age dressed up in the
white shirts and the ties and stuff like
that.
Is that a scientology or a mormon?
That's a more memory more.
I just,
I laugh.
What are some of the nicest fucking
people I have to take?
It might be but are so nice.
I can't stop laughing at them.
You know?
It's just ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous.
The whole look.
It's all ridiculous though.
It's not that,
you know,
being a Muslim isn't ridiculous,
but being a Jew is everything's
ridiculous.
Being a Catholics,
Being a president,
Protestants,
ridiculous.
Being a baptist,
being a Buddhist is ridiculous.
Being an anything is ridiculous.
You're a fucking human being and if you
attach,
you attach yourself and your mind to any
ideology,
you're going to be on a road and that
road may or may not lead you in a good
direction,
but you're going to stay on that fucking
road.
If you're attached to an ideology,
and it could be a terrible road,
it could be a road of circumcising,
your daughter's cliteracy because that's
a fucking tradition.
I mean these fucking crazy bitches in
Africa that cut holes in their lip and
stretch them out to put plates on.
Why is that?
Because they got on a fucking road and
they stick.
They stuck with that road regardless of
rational thinking.
They didn't use rational thinking at
all.
They're just adapted a predetermined
pattern or behavior that makes life so
much more simple and that's what every
fucking religion is.
The problem is no one knows.
You cannot.
No.
You can have your own beautiful personal
experiences.
You could have been the person that was
actually touched by God,
but when you start yelling and ranting
that other people have to follow your
lead or the fucking world's gonna end
and Christian is going to be taken away.
I know you're full of shit.
I know you're full of Shit and you know
you're full of shit.
And the real problem is that we can't
say it because everybody's got this
freedom of religion,
religious freedom,
the freedom to express yourself.
Even if you're expressing yourself with
nonsense.
Nonsense that helps.
Scared,
lonely,
sad.
People lock onto that nonsense so they
feel like they're a part of something.
I mean,
that's what it is.
It preys on people whose lives fucking
suck.
So it's all nuts.
It's not like your shit's cool and my,
it's not.
And it's not that,
you know,
Yoga is the answer or fucking mushrooms
are the answer.
There's,
there's just questions and until we're
honest about that,
we're never going to evolve.
The human race is stuck in a giant
quagmire when it comes to our behavior
and our thinking about our behavior.
Yeah,
totally.
And you know,
and one thing is like they all look like
from the Geek squad,
these at these Mormon guys on 10 states.
Can you imagine though if they mixed it
up and like showed up with like,
you know,
Harry chess and necklaces and like rave
clothes on and sunglasses.
Sorry.
That would be if the Mormons came to
your house.
Just started rocking it.
Yeah.
Like they pull up,
pull up in like a,
you know what it says new Chevy's
whatever.
Yeah.
Man,
I don't,
I don't think the world's ready for like
a hip religion yet.
There was some work that we're doing
with rock and roll churches.
Remember that?
Yeah.
They still have those.
That is still popular.
Really popular.
My name is,
there was a girl that used to work at
fear factor.
She's a very nice girl and she uh,
was,
you know,
trying to fireplace and she started
going to a rock and roll church saying
how much I would really love this rock
and roll church could even though this
guy's talking about God,
he's really all just about being
positive.
And that's the vehicle that he uses for
a lot of people,
man,
religion can give you some inspiration,
but there comes a certain point in time
where you have to pop the training
wheels off and you have to recognize
that all this mortality that you've
developed is good because it's good to
treat other people good.
It's good to treat other people the way
you would like to be treated yourself.
It's like a fucking golden rule and
there's a reason for it,
and that reason is that we're connected
in some strange way that we don't
totally understand.
Unless you are good to other people
around you,
unless you were kind and friendly and
warm and loving,
you're not going fucking enjoy this
life.
You're just not.
You're going to be problems everywhere
you go.
You're going to have problems everywhere
You got to figure out a way to enjoy
this fucking life.
It's not because of Jesus.
It's not because of Moses.
It's not because of anybody that may or
may not have ever existed.
It's because that's how you fit in
better in the world.
That's how you stay positive and it
doesn't have to some shit that was
written
5,000
years ago and fucking animal skins.
That doesn't have to be the golden rule
because it's old,
you know?
That's dumb.
We need to figure out like now,
today,
what is the best way to live your life?
What is the,
you know there.
There's got to be ways for you can be
putting forward the most positive
energy.
I mean,
we know objective Lee,
what's causing pollution.
We know objective really what's causing
birth defects and you know,
and we're taking it too much chemicals
and not enough vitamins.
We know objective,
we all this stuff.
We know how to organize our world and
yet we don't do it.
We know how to organize our health and
yet very few people do it.
We know all these things.
The right path to like being like a
happy,
healthy person is to do all the shit
that we already know you're supposed to
do.
Take care of your body,
take care of your health,
take care of your mind.
You're stress.
Meditate.
Be kind to people.
We all know that.
I mean,
you ask anybody,
they know how to get by and to be the
the most evolved version of you that you
can be.
I mean,
it's not like a magical checklist.
If you talked to people about it,
you said,
okay,
here you got a person.
You want to improve them.
What are the things you're gonna do to
them?
Okay,
well,
if I was a life coach,
the first thing I would say is this
guy's got to get on a diet that makes
them healthy.
I don't mean to die just to lose weight.
I mean just healthy foods in your body.
Many,
many vegetables,
vegetables,
a lot of good,
good quality protein,
a lot of water stopped the sodas.
Stop the bullshit.
Start working out your body and get a
better sense of like how this machine
feels.
When it's moving,
it's flowing better.
There's less tension in it.
Your mind feels like relaxed and you
enjoy every single moment of the day
better.
Step one,
everybody knows that step,
right?
What step to be cool to people.
Be Nice to as many people as you can,
smile and as many people as you can,
have them smile back at you.
Tip well,
when you go to restaurants,
just do the most.
You can be as nice as you can,
you know,
and just still managed to not have
people walk all over you just get
through this life and it's nice as you
can.
What else?
Do what you want to do with your life,
right?
Don't,
don't go be doing something you don't
enjoy.
Don't do something that's don't get
locked into,
you know,
a car that you can't afford and doing
something crazy because you need the
money.
Don't,
don't do that.
Do what you want to do.
Do what the fuck is it that you really
want to do because if someone else is
doing it,
you can do it.
You know?
I mean everybody makes their own path
through this world,
but a lot of people don't follow the
path that they really fucking feel
pulled to.
You know,
for whatever reason,
they got negative programming and then
when they were kids,
someone told them they couldn't do it or
told them to take the shortcut or,
or take the,
uh,
the,
the shorter route.
That's a sad thing,
man.
When he talked to dudes,
especially like talented dudes and they
don't follow up with what they want to
do.
You know,
nobody like that.
I don't know,
but I was just thinking to your list
that I think you should never stop
tickling people and I don't know why
it's looked down upon because I enjoy
making people laugh,
you know,
including tickling,
forcing them to laugh.
I don't like people to him.
Why are you ticklish ticklish where you
tickle tickle,
you know?
Do you
know where ticklish.
This is an interesting subject.
You know where this comes from,
it's an evolutionary trait and it's from
being freaked out instantly and
immediately about spiders and insects
crawling on you because if you're
sleeping on the ground,
yeah,
because if you're sleeping on the ground
and some things on you and you fucking
move like that,
that's what ticklish.
It's.
You're trying to avoid these instant
reactions to these weird sensitive areas
or body,
especially things where things can crawl
like under your armpits.
You touched my armpit.
I'll jump through the fucking roof.
I've fuck it,
but that's what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like this is all.
It's an evolutionary thing.
It did not know.
That makes sense.
Of course.
Why else would you have this extreme
reaction on the bottom of your feet?
That's where you're stepping on things.
Not Ticklish at all though.
I mean,
because there's topes and they're
supposed to die because,
you know,
I dated this girl that I even went to
the unit that she was willing to date
you so fucked up.
That's a b.
um,
she's,
she's ready to be bitten by a spider.
I always go for the Butler was the last
move though,
like if you're not tick less of your
tickets in the butthole and then it
usually gets them.
You ever watch a porno where a girl's
got a rubber butthole and you're like,
this is ridiculous.
How is this chick taking this?
The ass pound in the ass?
Yeah.
How do they do that?
I don't know,
but I'm seeing the Bella,
Donna one.
She's crazy and so it's talked about
them in the podcast before we.
We looked it up and then we found out
there was like we looked up a baseball
bat porn because we thought it would
only be one bella.
Donna video.
No.
Was like a bunch of videos.
Chicks with bats up the Ras.
I think it's once a girl puts a bat up
her ass.
Then the,
the,
the porn guys like to come to the other
checks and go see,
look,
she's willing to do it,
but you don't want to do it.
You don't want to work.
He just can add it to your resume.
That's an icon.
Next.
Her job that you would get that you
wouldn't have got before too.
Dark roads on.
It's kind of weird.
I would like to see like the resumes of
some of these girls will do baseball
bats.
Eat Donkey ass.
Fucking funny story.
There was a dude,
uh,
that was uh,
friends with a friend of mine.
I didn't know the guy that well,
but uh,
he was dating a porn star and uh,
he was like trying to be cool with it
because he didn't have any money and she
was,
you know,
paying the bills and shit and he was,
I think it was a musician and she came
home with a contract and it was just,
you know,
it's just sex ban.
So big deal.
Yeah.
I'm allowed to fuck other girls from on
the road to,
you know,
we're just open,
still a big deal and she doesn't fuck
any of those guys when she's not working
with them,
you know,
the whole deal.
He had this whole rationalization thing
and then he got a contract and he's
going over the contract and he goes,
what's this,
what's this?
What's this airtight?
What does that mean?
And she goes,
airtight is one of my mouth,
one of my asshole and one of my posting.
And he goes this,
this relationship's over,
this fucking threw in the towel,
right?
Then in there he's like,
what,
what's,
but at the same time,
one in your asshole,
one of your,
and they have a name for it.
Okay.
And you're about to go air tight?
Yeah,
I'm done.
That's it.
But a fucking.
Forget it.
And Hooker.
Triple Rainbow.
Damn.
First of all,
you know any girl that would let you do
that?
Any girl.
Whoa.
Any girl that wants to that.
And any girl that is in a relationship
with a man is like cool with her doing
that.
You've got a whole lot of problems.
There was,
there was this girl who was a.
there's this guy,
I'm a nice Einstein up a Salami was his
name Steve.
I think he lives in Seattle now.
Cool Dude.
He was a producer.
Didn't like it.
Got Out of it.
You said the whole business is just
fucked up.
It's all crazy and everyone's a mess and
he just wants to be a healthier person.
So now he's teaching Jujitsu.
Super Nice Guy.
So anyway,
um,
he uh,
tells us,
hey man,
come,
come see me.
We're,
we're doing a porno shoot,
uh,
come,
come watch it.
It's pretty fun.
So uh,
I was with tate and we're like,
all right,
fuck it.
We'll go.
And we just got back from the road.
We just landed from some gig and this is
one.
Tate was staying with me.
So before we went to my house,
we just drove to this guy's fucking
porno.
Shoot me right out of the airport,
right?
We walk in the door,
we walk in the door and there's this one
guy with guns tattooed on his body.
He's got like guns,
like,
yeah,
one of those dudes.
And then the other guy is just this
regular muscle looking dude and they are
ruining this bitch.
They are ruining her.
One guy is pounding her asshole with his
deck and one guy is fucking her mouth
and every couple of seconds they pull
her off off the Deq and spit in her
mouth.
So this girl goes to this terrible day
of all this spitting fucking around.
It's all fucking her pussy.
And then when it's all over she goes
into the shower and she wants everyone
to piss in her mouth.
So these porno stars start peeing in her
mouth.
And she sits there with her mouth open
and then that she wants a director do
it.
You get over here.
So the director goes over and he pees in
her mouth and I am watching this whole
thing.
I'm like,
this might be the saddest shit I've ever
seen in my life.
This girl is on her knees in the shower.
Okay.
The water's pouring all over.
She's totally wet.
She's been pounded in the asshole in the
mouth all day.
Two dudes have taken turns spitting in
her mouth of three dudes because the
director did it to spitting them out to
everybody was spending in her mouth.
And now she's on her knees and there's a
dude pissing in her mouth and they're
filming it.
And I'm like,
wow.
So then she goes,
my boyfriend's going to pick me up at
four or something like that.
And we're like,
your boyfriend a man.
And I didn't want to talk to her.
I didn't want to be mean.
I didn't want to be judgmental.
I didn't want to say anything.
I,
I introduced myself.
Hi Joe.
Nice to meet you.
I'm going to watch you.
Fuck me.
And my friend tate here,
we're gonna sit and watch you get
fucked.
So we were sitting like maybe 10 feet
away from this standing,
standing maybe 10 feet away while
there's these two dudes were pounded on
this chick and then these guys,
pete and this girl's mouth.
And then she starts talking about her
boyfriend.
Where's your boyfriend doing?
He's a cook.
So like a short order cook at Denny's or
some shit like that.
And uh,
you know,
and I go,
is your,
is your husband?
I'm cool with all this cool that long as
I keep bringing them checks,
he's cool with it.
And so,
uh,
Taikos goes,
does a,
is he allowed to fuck anybody else?
She goes,
he better not,
I'll fucking kill him.
Oh my God,
whoa.
He better not,
I'll fucking kill.
I'm like,
what did I just watch?
This is just,
this might be the nuttiest fucking scene
I've ever been a part of that my whole
life.
I was like,
this is so strange.
And it's awful.
Do you remember her name?
Her name or anything?
No idea.
I wouldn't remember her face.
Her name.
Anything.
I'd never seen her before.
Again,
there's so many of them.
Dude,
there's so much porn going on out here.
There's so many dudes that I know.
I know.
So many guys from Jujitsu.
Tyler night,
I know him.
He's a porn dude.
Very cool guy.
He's got a really awesome blog too.
He writes about Gangbang scenes and shit
like that.
And uh,
Jake Steve used to train a Machado's and
then there was another dude that used to
train the Machados Titi Boi.
And then,
uh,
John,
the form,
that's his real name.
I'm not supposed to.
Vince Vaughn,
Vince for is another fucking male porn
stars.
Just like a gang of a man.
There's like all these porn guys.
There's so many,
so much porn going on out here.
It's ridiculous.
They're all girls come out here with
like,
you know,
whatever issues and you know,
looking for a dream.
And a lot of them it doesn't work out.
And the next thing you know they're
doing porn and then there's girls that
just have always wanted to get into porn
and then they just fucking like Sasha
grey type checks.
They come here when they're 18,
good to go,
ready to suck dick on film.
It's kind of depressing actually,
but it makes the grocery store at 2:00
AM a lot better,
you know,
because you're just walking around and
there were some porn chick has wasted.
Try and get cantaloupes.
It's way worse when you have kids.
Dude,
and I bet I have a hard time beating off
to porn these days.
Yeah,
I have to shut off the compassionate
part of my brain.
Really Compassionate part of my brain
months ago.
Okay.
What if this is my daughter with,
you know,
my daughter was doing this and guys were
holding her eyelids open and judges and
inner eyeball,
you know,
I've watched that the other day and I'm
like,
what the fuck?
Someone's baby.
Someone's a little baby girl.
You know,
someone's fucking her mouth like that.
Maybe she likes it,
you know,
some girls do like that.
So you can't,
can't say always that it's terrible,
but you know for a chances are if you're
getting pounded in a porno film,
that's not really what you want to be
doing.
You should try to figure out something
else that you can masturbate to like
start like getting attracted to
something on purpose to try to.
Someone's going to come up with anime
porn.
Yeah.
It would just go over some fucking
awesome CGI,
you know,
use the quick for engine.
Yeah.
You know,
once it gets to the point where um,
pornography can be artificially created,
then it'd be way better.
It was Karma Free Porn.
Today's a day that doc set the time
machine to go back to and back to the
future.
But really?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
How do you know that?
Somebody tweeted it earlier today.
I didn't research it,
so it might be fake.
Could you imagine if they really do
invent a time machine one day?
Because the real thing about time
machines that people aren't aware of,
there's scientists that actually tried
to like study time travel and whether or
not there's a guy's fucking awesome
story.
His name is Ronald Malate.
Dr Ronald Mouth,
I believe from Connecticut.
See if you google that shit.
See if that's his name.
But anyway,
the guy has a fantastic story.
He's,
he's like the leading scientists when it
comes to a theoretical models for time
trap.
What was his name?
Ronald Malate from I believe University
of Connecticut and he.
He has like a working model yet is
Ronald Mallon.
He has a working model of a m,
a l,
l e t,
t or one,
one tier two t's,
tt.
Who else?
M a l l e t,
t look him up on Google and there's some
videos about him,
but his dad died.
It's a crazy story.
His Dad died when he was a kid and he
was so hurt.
He loved his father and his whole,
his photos of him and his father and his
father smile and he smiled.
He was so close to his father.
When his father died,
it crushed him and so he dedicated his
life to creating a time machine.
He dedicated his life to creating a time
machine so that he could go back in time
and save his father so his father would
be with him again.
So that was the entire focus of his life
and he got to a certain point where he
realized that you can someday it is
possible to travel back in time,
but it's not something that you're going
to be able to go back to any point in
history.
You're only going to be able to go back
in time to the moment that the first
time machine was invented.
So what we'll be able to be possible is
you will be able to.
The moment there is a time machine
invented,
you'll that day.
From that day on,
you'll be able to go to any point in
history that you want.
So you can go to,
you know,
assuming there's human beings around,
assuming the world hasn't been hit by
another planet or some crazy shit,
you'll be able to go to 1 million years
from now.
Let's see what the world looks like 1
million years from now.
Because there will be time machines
functional back then or in that feature.
But the problem is then,
this is the,
this is all theoretical,
but the problem is that any moment in
time could also go back to the moment,
the first time she was invented.
So if you can travel back in time from
any moment in time,
that's like millions of years,
in fact,
infinite.
If people are still alive,
have of time of years of people going
back to the moment of the first time
machine being invented.
So it's literally like the whole notion
of time gets broken,
you know,
there's no,
there's no real future.
It all kind of happens all at once.
So literally fucks with the entire
fabric of the universe.
Everything can come back to the moment
that the first time machine was
invented.
It like breaks everything.
So this is like real shit.
They're working on like this.
This guy is like really convinced that
this is a possible thing.
That's craziness.
Here's something else I had back to the
future three.
If you look at the very end of the movie
when dox has his kids and he's like
telling like cmit everything's going to
be good,
you know,
look at one of the kids,
the kids starts going like this,
like come here or put something in my
hand and then he points to his dick what
it is.
So ridiculous and just got snuck through
somehow it snuck through.
But I'm talking about like a six old to
people were so stupid back then.
They didn't even know.
So yeah.
You could find on youtube,
like back to the future three points to
package.
Is that one of those movies that you go
watch it today and it would disappoint
the shit out of?
Yeah.
Not so good.
I mean I saw the first one the other day
and it was okay,
but then I saw the third one was just so
dumb.
I didn't even want to watch it.
Yeah,
man,
the evolution of movies has been pretty
fucking pretty obvious.
The evolution of what we accept,
you know?
Yeah.
Like people talk about avatar being
silly and ridiculous,
but still you see toy story three yet?
No,
I heard it's awesome,
isn't it?
Are the best.
All that animation stuff,
which just freaks me the fuck out.
I was reading and wired there.
There's some insane amount of time for
like every frame for as far as like,
um,
rendering something like seven our
fucking time for each frame to render.
Is that insane?
Which movie though?
This campaign now.
Really?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Hmm.
That seems like it would be better than
I could go into the living room and go
get that a,
that magazine,
but I don't know exactly where it is and
I don't want to get up.
But the idea is that it's still,
even to this day,
it's very difficult to do the whole,
um,
even if my timeframe is wrong,
the whole.
Why don't you just go look under wired
pixar,
Pixar,
not pixel.
Um,
but it's,
it's still not quite there yet as far as
like the technology that's going to
exist one day where you can create
instant artificial people.
You know,
you remember like the editing that
you're doing right now just with final
cut on just doing on a regular home
computer.
An apple mean that this is the kind of
shit that 10 years ago it was like
fucking dreaming.
You're dreaming bitch.
Like you're gonna what you're going to
be able to edit and how fast is it gonna
render we're going to put shit together.
It's that easy.
Twenty years ago.
Science fiction,
right?
Twenty years ago,
science fiction,
30 years ago,
super crazy.
Science fiction.
It's like ridiculous.
You're talking,
you're talking about something that's
just like people would look at in the
movies and go,
wow,
you know,
like minority report type shit.
Yeah.
Well they make it look like you can do
it now,
but it really is not going to exist for
another 100 years or so.
What did you say?
How many hours?
I think they said seven.
Yeah,
that's what they.
Just seven hours.
Seven hours.
Seven hours per pixel.
What the fuck,
man?
That's all I got super computer to
write.
I don't think it was like A.
I'm sure they use.
Yeah,
a huge cloud of computers.
Definitely.
That's ridiculous.
Those movies took a lot of fucking time,
but God damn,
they're cool as fuck.
So 77 hours now.
So in 10 years,
that means we could do pixar movies on
her phone.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's inevitable,
right?
It's going to be awesome.
Hey Dude,
check off toy story 80.
Huh?
If they don't break the universe before
then.
Yeah.
All right.
That's my latest.
The human beings created the big bang.
I've been talking about on that stage.
I think that's what we're doing.
I think that's.
I think that's why the big,
I think 14,
14 billion years ago plus was the big
bang.
I think it was a lonely dude in his
basement and figured out a way to break
the universe and they had a switch and
they wanted to see what happened and
they clicked it and the whole thing,
you just want to.
I think that's what happens.
And then,
and then you know,
people get curious and we developed to a
certain point in time where we repeat
the process.
Isn't that possible?
I mean,
nobody knows what the fuck created the
Big Bang,
right?
But when you see scientists working on
shit like the large Hadron collider,
the large Hadron collider is this crazy
experiment that they're participating
right now in Europe where they've got
this 22 kilometer long machine and it
spins these,
Adam's around and collides them.
It's just just slightly slower than the
speed of light and they're trying to
recreate a thing called the Higgs Boson
particle.
Now they believe there's actually five
different higgs boson particles are
trying to figure out like what,
what existed.
They call it the God particle for lack
of a better word.
And it's what existed just a
millisecond,
you know,
a fraction of a millisecond evening,
uh,
right after the big bang.
So when they get that,
when they figured out how to do that,
and if they do recreate the Higgs Boson
and if they do really,
you know,
find out it's not just a theoretical
particle,
but it's real.
When they do that,
they're not going to stop there.
But I have stop there.
They're got to keep going.
They're going to the what's the next
thing this is they got 10,000
scientists working on that.
This is the biggest project in
scientific history and it has nothing to
do with making our lives better.
Technology at one point in time was all
about making your life better.
Technology was about,
you know,
hey,
we need to get water and we don't want
to,
you know,
just have to drink it out of the river
every time we would need to get it and
bring it back to camp.
What do we do?
We figured out how to make a jug.
That's technology technology today.
The Shit like the Higgs Boson particle
shaped like the large Hadron collider
shit.
Like making time machines.
Like what are you doing?
Like what the fuck are you doing?
You're not fixing the hole in the ground
and the Gulf that's making the oil
polar.
Shouldn't they pull all the scientists
off everything and go,
okay,
we got to fix this before the whole
ocean gets poisoned.
I've always wondered why they don't do
that.
Anyway,
so with cancer it's just like,
all right guys,
we're going to take all the sciences
that wants to cancer one year.
Do it.
You know,
these guys aren't experts in their
fields.
Obviously.
You mean I can't know everything about
everything.
It's a silly concept.
I mean what I'm saying,
but it would be great if they took all
the top scientists from all the
different disciplines that would be
involved and they immediately allocated
funds to get them to work on the project
instantly and just the government stuff.
I mean I'm not in favor of the
government stepping in,
but in this case I would say this is not
just a natural disaster.
This is a fucking catastrophic disaster
where apocalyptic disaster where they
need to step in and do something about
this immediately.
They need to like impose like almost
like a martial law type of a thing.
Take over the whole,
you know,
but then again,
who's going to be good that's doing that
for the government.
The government would have to involve the
private sector and the private sector
would try to make a lot of money from it
and would try to fuck people over and it
would be a big scandal.
It'd be like Halliburton and they'd find
out billions of dollars are missing from
the whatever.
My fucking idea sucks.
You see that baby and China.
I was born with a second food.
I did and I didn't want to look.
I saw it and I shut it off.
That shit depresses the fuck out of
them.
It's pretty amazing.
Now it's,
I mean it's a second face.
It kind of looks like,
what does that movie a Phantom of the
opera or whatever,
but it's.
I mean,
did you say there were gonna be able to
fix the kid or I'll do it.
I didn't really depresses the shit out
of me.
Just like the one that I saw the other
day where there was a baby that was
born.
It was like a fish baby,
like skin had this very strange disease.
That shit so depressing to me,
man.
You know,
fucked at birth and especially man,
it's depressing when you find out that
it's due to birth defects because of
chemicals,
people that worked at factories and you
know,
people that were given chemicals they
shouldn't have been given while they
were pregnant.
And Man,
China,
China's a tricky place right now.
Man.
China has some of the most polluted
cities in the world.
Have you ever seen the videos on that
you're seeing is that the same wherever
there are dropping like our old
computers and cell phones are all going
there.
Is that China?
I don't know.
Do they go to China?
He had that somewhere they go and it's
just cities that are like kind of like,
what's that wally movie with cities of
just old computers and stuff like that.
Let's find out where they go.
Let's find out because I never heard of
that before.
No,
but I do know that China has terrible
Belushi pollution problems and there was
one city where they showed it.
Was it a VBS DOT TV doc?
Some doc that I watched on the most
polluted city in the world and just one
day in this city,
just just breathing the air is like
smoking three packs of cigarettes a day.
Wow.
So every fucking day you're there,
you're smoking three packs of cigarettes
a day.
The Sky was brown,
man.
It was crazy.
Like you couldn't see shit like it was.
It took smog to an les nasty dude.
When you come over,
like when you're coming from the valley
and he'd come over that hill and you see
everything brown and you can't even see
the fucking mountains outside of
Pasadena.
You can't see the mountains and you look
at it and you go,
what the fuck are we doing to the EHR?
That ain't shit compared to China,
right?
China five times worse than that.
It is the nuttiest shit you've ever seen
in your life.
I don't know what kind of laws they
have.
I don't know how to get away with shit
like that,
but the factories just palm shit out.
What is this?
So we have a photo.
You found the dangers of old computers.
There's a computer wasteland.
Does it say what country China,
China,
meaning Irish,
China.
It's about to smash.
Everybody keeps going off about how
great the economy is in China and
China's becoming like a capitalist
economy and you know,
Chinese people are,
you know,
the whole country is,
it's changing and flourishing and we
owe.
America owes China so much.
And then you look at what China's really
doing,
like con cam or a foxconn rather.
Right?
Isn't that the name of the company?
Foxconn.
Foxconn is where all those guys who are
working for apple keep killing
themselves.
They help make an iphone speaking
enough.
How do you like your new iphone?
I had to get a new one.
Yeah?
Yeah.
How to get a new one.
What happened?
Wouldn't accept the SIM card.
Kept saying my.
I didn't have a Sim card.
Oh yeah.
Crazy.
I don't know what happened.
It just kept doing.
It.
Kept saying no Sim card,
no Sim card.
And so finally,
eventually out to bring it back to them.
You said you want to see live meet going
from three bars to zero service.
Oh,
okay.
This is.
This is the thing where if you touch the
bottom,
it says it does something to show it.
Okay.
If you don't know,
nobody could say this man.
This fucking web cameras sucks.
Bars.
You got at least you have a couple bars,
right?
Well,
just just do it and tell us what's
happening.
Yeah,
it's going.
It's going from.
I just went to 83.
It was on for actually,
um,
it's now two.
Oh Wow.
And it's now going to go to one any
second now.
So just slowly drops.
Yeah.
You know what apple says?
They say that it's an error in the
followings.
Wild dropped down.
The one that's crazy that's going to go
to no service.
Now they say that it's a,
an error in the phones computing and
that it is a,
it's not an error saying searching.
Wow,
okay.
Let it go now and then it'll go back up.
And so apple's trying to say that it's
not a real problem.
They're trying to say that what you're
getting is just a more accurate
representation of the signals.
Wow.
Now it's got a signal which is whack.
That doesn't make any sense because if
they're saying what they're saying is
like,
if this is wrong,
if you don't have three bars right now,
you actually have one bar and covering
up the antenna will make it go down.
I just know it's a stupid.
It's a stupid thing to say because okay,
so you're saying that the phone just
calculates the bars incorrectly and
really when you touch it a certain way,
then it calculates them.
Right.
What do you,
what does that the truth button the fuck
are you talking about?
You have,
you have a button and it's a part of the
phone and if you touch it,
it tells.
It makes the phone honest with you.
That's stupid.
That's a hardware problem.
You cocksucker right?
It doesn't deal with the case,
which,
which is good because I never used my
iphone without a case.
Anyway.
He a signal here,
man,
you should get.
So yeah,
I got it.
And when you had no signal,
that's not normal.
Right?
But the problem is is what are they
going to really do about it?
Is this software update just going to
make all the.
Everyone that just not happen,
you're just going to always have lower
signal than normal.
I don't know.
I just,
I don't buy it.
Somebody just made up a whack excuse.
Right?
Because if they didn't make up a whack
excuse,
they would've had to have some massive
fucking recall.
Yeah.
People would have gone nuts.
There's class action lawsuit in the
works.
Yeah,
but they said that it does.
It does it on the three g and the past.
But I tried on my three gs.
I couldn't do it.
I try as video online though top.
Oh really?
I couldn't do it.
Maybe they broke theirs or something.
Maybe it was older models.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Too stupid way to deal with the issue.
They'll tell people they have to buy a
bumper,
especially when you're selling poppers
for 30 bucks,
which is kind of Douchey in and of
itself.
You know,
like why?
How come if I drop it,
it's fucked.
Right.
So you get that bump,
so you give me this little thing to put
around it.
Oh,
how much does this little thing?
30 bucks.
This is 30 bucks and only apple makes it
and it should have came with a fucking.
You got a blackberry the other day.
I came with a leather case.
I can't get a little piece of rubber,
you know,
so I went to best buy and I bought two
of the only cases that best buy sells,
you know,
that covered the back,
right.
So,
uh,
the first one I put on it was so tight
and poorly made,
I think it was Belkin that the top
button just automatically was always
pushed down.
So it was just resetting my phone over
and over.
So I had a second one that was going to
give to you and I opened that one and
tried it again.
Same thing.
Went Online,
found out that's a problem with the
case.
So then I bought this other one from
griffith that had a,
a plastic back to it.
Uh,
and every time you took a photo it would
flash and hit the plastic and flashback
into the camera.
And every photo look like shit.
I went back online.
Same exact thing across the board.
So the only case we can get right now is
this one that will protect you.
Fix that.
How do they not have cases for an
iphone?
Come on.
Apple.
We were one.
Alright.
So if I break this,
you're going to replace the back because
there's no other fucking case.
What are and what is the deal with this?
This glass on the back.
Why do you have glass on the floor?
Reception issues means looking at what
it is.
Yeah,
it's what it's supposed to be for.
It's supposed to be for better
reception.
Wow.
It mean,
come on.
When you're carrying a piece of glass in
your pocket,
what are the odds?
Are things going to break and stab your
fucking like decorating for the first
person to sit on the back of their phone
and get us up there ass hole and they
die.
What do you think a month to imagine
that?
That's how he died on an iphone at went
up your ass and that killed you.
Yeah.
What was that guy that used to the 30
ways to die or whatever.
Ninety nine ways to die.
He put glass things up his ass and sat
on them.
Remember he had this fetish of putting a
glass,
whatever.
That was a bad one of those episodes.
Yeah.
Really?
That shows disturbing as fuck.
Like different people have died.
Spike's doing good with their shows.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
That's a good short attention span show.
He just slip in and you know,
anytime you're flipping through the
channels and they'll start like a real
kind of like a,
um,
what's the word?
Just a hokey sort of a reenactment,
you know,
where it's,
there's like a certain amount of humor
to it,
you know,
and they know what they're going to show
you a fucked up way.
Somebody died.
It's kind of creepy,
but it's interesting to me because then
I think about all these have that extra
thought every time you know,
I want to shove something up my ass.
I know I might die from it,
you know,
you know what I do know.
I do know it's a hard urge to resist
shoving your ass.
Sometimes it just overcomes you or,
or just crossing the street with my eyes
closed,
you know,
whatever you've seen oriented showed me
one guy in one cup,
didn't you?
Somebody did
one guy,
one cup.
I think you showed it to me.
I don't look for those things anymore.
That was the one where the guy put a jar
up his asshole.
Right.
And then he sat down and his asshole
crushed the jar and chunks of glass and
blood start falling out of this guy's
body and he doesn't even freak out.
That's the most disturbing part of.
But I still don't know if I believe
everything anymore.
Oh,
I believe that one.
I don't know if that's a fake glass.
Even if that's not fake.
Someone needs a Goddamn Academy award.
Bme Pan Olympics was fake.
No,
it's not.
A lot of that is not fake.
It's all fake.
People say it's fake.
I don't believe that that knows the most
about.
I have it on my wife's side.
Parts of that were real.
It wasn't that one.
It wasn't one of them to cut his finger
off.
Huh?
Wasn't that the BME?
No,
no,
no.
The Olympics where they're just chopping
their balls off and stuff like that.
I read to me,
man,
they're all the same.
Yeah,
they're all the.
All the.
All the violence go together.
I know there's one word got cut his
finger off where it's absolutely real
yet.
I'm sure that might be real.
There's fucking crazy guy with the jar
up his ass.
Real dude.
It's really pretty.
Pretty obvious.
It's real.
You believe we don't chase them nasty.
I don't know what the fuck happened to
that dude when he was a kid that made
them want to shove bottles up his
asshole and having a crush inside of
them and then drop out.
What happened?
What is it?
Lindsay Lohan's.
Mom.
Do you think that will do it?
Fuck yeah.
Can Imagine Lindsay Lohan as your mom
and fucking that dude from Jack Ass
Steevo as your dad.
Do you think she can get pregnant?
Uh,
no.
She's probably so good.
Like you said,
we just saw that she was 24 I thought
for sure.
She was like over 30.
I forgot all about.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I wonder if I could.
Hard action man that ships out there
doing it every night.
Yeah,
you're the one that told me that she got
a tooth pulled just so she'd get back on
Vicodin so closely when she got that
scrapbook brace it on or whatever it's
called,
that she immediately had a dentist's
appointment the next day that was
supposedly priorly,
you know,
uh,
prior to this,
whatever.
And she had a tooth pulled or she had
something she had done,
but it was like,
oh,
now she's allowed to have [inaudible]
and that's really,
that's nice for her.
So.
So she's got this crazy bracelet on,
so to stay sober and the dentist gives
her,
first of all,
she don't need to get fucking Viking and
I've had teeth pulled.
I've had shit happen.
You just deal with it.
It's not that bad.
I have a knee surgery.
They didn't take pain medication.
I took violin when I had my first acl
reconstruction and made me feel so
stupid.
It just made me feel so dumb and I sold
them some dude at the pool hall.
Let's do named Jeff.
You did not do that?
Yes.
You sell them.
I sold them to Jeff and jeff sold them
all throughout the pool.
People Gobble those and ends up.
They love him.
I had a friend who was a guitarist.
He used to say that it made him more
creative.
What?
That's the opposite effect it does to
mean to me.
It makes me feel fucking useless.
And Dom,
that's all it does,
but I think everybody's brain is
working,
working differently.
Men,
I mean slightly.
I think we all have different levels of
different chemicals and different.
You know,
his music was probably fucking retarded
then.
Well,
no,
he was.
No,
he was a classical guitarist who is
really good.
He was like,
he wouldn't like competitions shit.
It was fucking bad ass.
Worst song ever.
Competition.
No Man.
He would play songs that already
existed,
you know,
like Spanish Franca songs,
that kind of Shit.
He was just,
he's a brilliant guitarist and he said
we'd take vodka and it would make them
more creative.
I don't know,
but you know,
everybody's brains.
He's a fucking crazy dude.
Who was a former,
a taekwondo champion,
my friend Dimitri,
and he was a big fucking burly,
manly giant dude from the Ukraine,
you know,
his family's a bunch of fucking savages,
much of a Russian fucking animals,
and maybe the Vicodin just helped calm
his inner monkey enough so that he
could.
He could tune into his creative spirit,
you know?
Yeah.
Everyone's different,
right?
This dude's the only dude that I've ever
talked to that said vicodins made them
creative as I could easily have been
that,
you know,
everybody's got their own fucking thing,
man.
I mean,
how many people have you come across
where you go,
this guy is just broken.
His brain's just not wired,
right?
His body's not wired right.
He just got the wrong levels of all
kinds of shit when he was in the womb.
Totally.
Portland,
and that's our message for Lindsey.
Hang in there,
girl.
You could.
You are going to get out in three
months.
And I think that's when little wayne
gets out to and you can get together and
make a fucking bad ass ed.
How about that?
That's brock says,
put your underwear on.
How about I've Lindsay starts fucking
rapping while she's in the,
in the pokey and comes out like some bad
ass bitch rapper.
He's going to get fucking laid so much.
It's probably,
she's probably gonna be in jail.
Yeah,
she's probably just gonna fuck her in
jail too.
She's in heaven.
She's going to come out with.
Has Been Hell.
Yes she is.
I didn't know this.
What she did a date.
Samantha Ronson or whatever.
Really Sweet Dj.
You know Djs.
I know San Francisco.
One Dj and I don't know why I know him
because everybody always talks about
that guy.
Tsl.
Craig,
Bro.
Sorry.
One of the dudes who works for the UFC.
I think he was the one who was telling
me about this.
The guy sells out these gigantic fucking
stadiums.
Might've been craig.
I'm not sure,
but he's like this huge,
huge,
huge fucking dj where he sells out like
just gigantic events all over the world.
They come to see this guy do dj and he
makes his own electronic music.
That's huge.
I love it.
But how do you know?
How do you find out about these guys?
Used to do my space,
but now penn,
Pandora,
Pandora.
Yeah,
just putting it in my space.
If you want to start off slow,
just put in fatboy slim and they make it
a radio station based off that or
something like that.
And we talked about this.
Pandora is pretty bad ass.
I like the idea of creating your own
radio station.
[inaudible] good stuff.
So Brock,
brock Lesnar and Shankar one.
That was cool.
Raisie Brian was there on the
floor.
What?
I'm so glad they did.
Oh yeah.
Rock is one of those people that they
don't have to worry about stopping.
It's going to take a few trains into
that.
It really stopped the guy.
So I'm glad that means you know,
I mean,
you know,
trains to the head.
But I mean he,
he,
they didn't stop it so I was happy.
I was just,
I was so scared they're going to stop
it.
Yeah.
Well you know,
it looked like they were gonna stop it.
I mean,
he was just covering up and Shankar was
bombing on them and props to referee
Josh Rosenthal because it wasn't for
Josh Rosenthal,
the,
you know,
someone easily could have pulled the
trigger earlier.
Right now there's a few guys that I
wouldn't have trusted in that situation,
but Josh saw that he was okay.
He was going to get through it and you
saw the change punches were coming
slower and slower and Shane,
unfortunately it just blew his wad.
He,
um,
you know,
he had an adrenaline dump,
I'm sure the excitement of the fact that
he had a,
the champ hurting on his back and that
he was on top and he's like,
this is over,
this fucking thing is over and it's
pounded and pounded on Panama.
And then also has like,
fuck,
there's two minutes left to go in this
round,
you know?
And then he's got to keep going.
And by the end of those two minutes,
there was nothing left.
He got back to his corner and literally
could barely get up.
His legs were barely walking and he was
fucked.
He said his legs seized up and he said
he just went out there and he tried to
do whatever he could,
but his body just was not responding.
He just completely adrenaline dumped and
completely blew out all of his energy.
But God damn does.
He hit him hard before that.
Holy Shit.
That fucking Shankar when can punch.
He had so hard.
He's so big,
but I think he's too big.
I think maybe like because he,
he had to lose 17 pounds to make a,
to 65,
so he's,
you know,
walking in like at like somewhere around
two 80 ish,
you know,
on the day of the fight.
So I think that might be too big for his
frame.
You know,
I think maybe he might be better off if
he was like 2:50,
you know,
just a little lighter.
But with more endurance,
his punches are still going to be
ridiculously powerful.
Nobody could stand up to the way that
guy hits his punches will still be
ridiculously powerful,
but he'll have a little bit more cardio.
You know,
brock is just physically a bigger guy.
Man.
Brock Brock really has a 270 pound man's
body means so wide.
He's just a big giant freak.
Carlin's not as wide,
you know,
he's still biggest fuck a big giant
hands and shit,
but you know,
I think brock maybe can carry a little
bit more weight naturally.
Then Shane can and these guys when they,
when they train really hard with weights
and power lifting and shit like that.
Yeah.
It makes you stronger.
It gives you a lot more muscle and that
muscle got to get fed.
It's going to get fed by blood,
but goddamn it was exciting as fuck
before it's for.
It was over.
How does you still have his mouthpiece?
Everything in his mouth.
Put it in yet.
Tasted tasted the taste of a warrior.
It's right over there.
He stuck it in.
My pocket was over.
I said I'm gonna sell that shit on Ebay,
but I'm just going to hang onto it now.
That's cool.
Fucking.
I'm a fan.
A trivia moment.
Plus it was a what a comeback.
When he came out for that second round,
his hands were up high and like,
you know,
you just knew this motherfucker's not
going away.
He got hit with some bombs and he was
still there and still in really good
shape and that was really the big
difference.
He took shane down,
gotten Shane's half card passed,
got on top of him,
got him in an arm triangle and put them
to sleep.
It was fucking sweet or put them to tap.
He would've gone to sleep.
He really cranked it tight and brock is
so gigantic.
You see,
they also call it a side joke.
There's two different versions of it.
There's one like this,
you do it like this and that's why it's
called an arm triangle,
but the way brock did,
I think he did it with a gable grip
where you do it like this where it's
more,
it's really more of a side choke,
but brock is so big and so fucking
strong that when he just crushes down
like that,
like you really don't have any options,
man,
you're going to go to sleep.
He just got much too much power and he's
just going to quash that whole area
between your arm and your neck and
everything's going to get smushed and
there's not going to be any air.
That was one of the best.
UFC is I think in a long time.
That was a dude.
I was standing up during the fight.
It was so exciting.
I couldn't fucking sit down.
I stood up.
That's awesome.
When,
when,
when a car would hit him and you know,
he went to the ground,
it was like,
it was the whole thing.
There was so much energy in the arena.
It was so unbelievable.
And then when brock took him down at the
end,
it was like the whole thing was just so
nice and then when they tapped like it
was just fucking craziness,
man.
There was so much energy.
I stood up like three or four times.
I don't do that,
man.
That's the only fight I've ever had to
stand up in the middle of it because it
was so crazy though.
Like as far as like sheer entertainment
value,
what a fucking fight.
There was a bunch of sheer entertainment
value fights that were just off the
charts like Liebman and Akiyama.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That was crazy,
man.
For sheer entertainment.
That fight was better than any fucking
movie that's ever been made.
Has there ever been any photos of his
face since then?
Uh,
leaving.
Yeah,
to leave.
It's probably fine.
It probably looks today like nobody had
them.
Really?
Yeah.
He's tough as fuck.
He can take a shot.
Dude.
He got nailed.
His legs went rubbery.
He bounces backwards for a second and
then starts walking forwards again,
like a fucking Zombie.
It was incredible.
He was,
he was like literally like right out of
28 days later.
It was fucking crazy.
He can take bombs bed.
He takes them right on the chin and it
keeps going.
The only person has been able to put
them away as Anderson Anderson's.
Just way too fast.
Way Too technical.
Way to fluid.
Just way to gifted Anderson is just on
another level,
but for a lot of other people,
man,
you know,
it's like Arturo God,
he couldn't fight with floyd mayweather.
He got in there with floyd mayweather.
He just couldn't compete.
He couldn't compete with the style.
He couldn't compete with the technical
superiority,
the speed,
the reflex is the,
the training.
Everything was superior and he just got
lit up.
But when he found someone like Micky
Ward,
who was like in his ball,
you know,
in his,
his range,
he put on some of the most incredible
fights ever.
It's just a matter of getting them the
right opponent and leave and keeps
getting better and better.
You know,
he,
he's like,
you know,
he's beating like high level guys.
You know Erin Simpson,
the guy who beat before he beat this guy
is a bad motherfucker.
Man.
Aaron's a serious fucking wrestler.
Strongest Shit.
Incredible endurance.
I mean,
he's just a.
his fight with Tom Lawler.
He got nailed from pillar to post in
that first round and then the second
round,
you know,
he came back and he fucking started
taking lower down in the third round.
He came back and won that round two and
wound up getting the decision when it
looked like he was a dead band.
The first round he was getting battered.
So this guy is tough as fuck.
So when leave and put them away,
it was like,
wow.
Like,
that's,
that's strong.
That's a strong statement,
you know.
And then the next fight to go right from
that,
two weeks later to fight Akiyama,
you know,
hockey,
yama is a fucking bad dude.
Man.
Knocked out Dennis kangs fast as fuck.
Awesome.
Judo,
real solid grappler,
you know,
he's a good dude.
So leaving to fucking sweet winds on
row.
And how about that?
Christophe Sinskey,
Stephan Bonner that,
that.
That's my second favorite.
The night attack like a man possessed.
That was odd.
He knew that like it was do or die time.
He had lost a coleman.
He had,
you know,
had the fight with Susan.
He was,
look,
that guy will always have a home in the
UFC because he's a part of the biggest
fight in the history of the sport,
the most important fight.
The fight that got everybody to pay
attention.
The fight with him and Stephan Bonner
when they were on spike TV when it was a
final,
the ultimate fighter,
the very first season people were so
many people were tuning in while the
fight was on that I think the.
The amount of people viewing the fight
by the fight,
by the time the first card start with
the first part of the cards started to
Stephan Bonner and forrest griffin,
forrest griffin fight.
They had it like doubled,
tripled,
quadrupled at one point in time.
Some insane number,
like six to 10 million.
They estimated,
I forget what it was,
but like some something crazy.
It was watching that fight when nobody
is watching spike tv before that just
people were calling their friends and
they were like,
dude,
you've got to fucking turn this on.
Turn on channel.
Whatever it is.
These two guys are beating the shit out
of each other.
And Forrest Griffin and Stephan Bonner
had like a movie fight.
It wasn't even real.
It was like a goddamn every which way,
but loose clint eastwood movie,
you know,
it was him fighting tank Murdoch.
They beat each other all over the
fucking place and kept coming one after
each other for 15 solid minutes.
There'll be backed out for a second,
you know,
so he'll always have like a strong place
in the organization.
They'll will always have,
always have love for that dude.
But he also knew that he wants to be,
you know,
back in the heat at at two.
Oh five.
He wants to be fighting up to his
potential and he knows he's had some
good outings and some not so good
outings that Jon Jones fight.
It was a tough loss.
He had three tough losses in a row.
So he stepped in like fucking wild man.
Felt like his life was on the line.
I was actually surprised to see him back
since the last one.
Yeah.
But I'm glad because I always liked that
guy.
Well,
you know,
he got,
he got 'em through when Coleman got
caught,
man Coleman called tour.
He got caught,
but right before coleman a coture or
last to go to a rather.
He beat her,
you know.
So are you surprised that like Kimbo was
not given an extra shot or.
Yes and no.
I see the point,
you know,
really if he wasn't Kimbo you would have
to cut them.
Matt Mitrione beat him down and it
looked like he was,
you know,
it didn't look like he was in the right
kind of condition.
It looks like he got really tired.
His technical prowess wasn't up to the
level of material and material and an
improved much more from his time on the
ultimate fighter.
And you also have to wonder about
Kimball's body.
Kimble had some real knee problems on
the show and the knee problems that he
had on the show.
They weren't like fixable things.
It's like bone on bone type shit.
Like he's worn out the cartilage and one
of his knees,
which means that you can't train as
hard,
you can't sprawl and you can't,
you know,
do the kind of wrestling training that
you need to kink it.
Your legs kicked the way you kind of
need to get kicked,
you know,
he's got like a pretty serious problem.
That problem kept him from fighting in
the main event or getting another,
a shot at getting back in the heat of
the sharp member.
He got eliminated and then they offered
it to him.
They offered him a fight and he passed
on the fight because it was knee.
That's not something that gets better.
So it's like,
unless he's got some sort of a cartilage
replacement surgery or I don't know what
they're even able to do these days,
he's got a problem with that knee and
that knee is going to keep them from
being able to train the way the way a
GSP thiago alves trains or you know,
any of the killers.
So it's,
you know,
I don't know.
I think you can still make a lot of
money off the guy and the guy still
wants to fight.
I look at it as like,
you know,
butter bean,
Maryland butter bean was king of the
four rounders.
You know,
it doesn't mean you don't use butter
being on your car just because it's not
going to beat Larry Holmes,
you know,
kept butter being out there.
Fuck it.
You know,
put them out there.
It's,
it's,
it's still entertaining.
You know,
it's like Chris,
I mean Chris Leben is,
you know,
he's battling it out with the best in
the world.
He's beaten,
Akiyama,
beaten,
you know,
he's,
he's starting to move up in the chain,
but the end of the rainbow for him was
always going to be Anderson Silva.
You know,
Anderson.
I mean,
look,
anybody can beat anybody on any given
day a zig zag.
You run into one of Chris' lievens
punches.
You could be in a lot of trouble,
but technically the two are so far
apart,
you know,
Anderson is in such a different level
athletically,
you know,
the,
his ease of movement,
you know,
it's just like,
what do you do?
You're not going to cut leap and why
would you cut them one of the most
entertaining fighters in the world.
So even if you can't beat Anderson,
you've got to keep them around.
Even if he can never beat the best guy
in the world,
which I'm not saying he can't,
you never know.
You never fucking know.
And he's improving and shit happens and
weirder things have taken place in this
world.
But if even if he doesn't,
if he never,
if he can never beat Anderson,
he should still be around because he's
awesome,
you know,
he's fucking fun as shit to watch.
So I think that about Kimbo too.
I think Kim was fun to watch and even
though he's not like that at the level
that,
you know,
a junior dos Santos is or Cain
Velasquez,
he's not at that level.
I mean you just got to match correctly.
Just just accept the fact that this guy
is never going to be a title contender.
And even though that's not really what
the UFC is all about,
UFC is the very best guys fighting the
very best guys.
It doesn't maybe hurt throwing a young
gun in there with a gatekeeper.
Make Kimbo a gatekeeper,
you know,
make um,
a,
a guy that you test young guys with.
I think that's key.
That makes it kind of interesting.
As long as kimball wants to keep doing
it.
And if he keeps losing and then you
know,
it gets to a point where nobody wants to
see him anymore,
then maybe stop using them.
What do you have a chance?
So what do you think Dana white would
say about having a UFC bar?
That was just in the middle.
There was an octagon and every night you
just go there and there's people
fighting constantly.
He couldn't do that.
Couldn't have that many people fighting.
No,
no.
You know it to be too hard to sanction
it.
It'll be too hard to ensure that
everybody had their proper medicals.
It'd be too hard to find qualified
fighters because they can't fight.
But you know,
I mean,
leaving thought Erin Simpson.
Then two weeks later he fought Akiyama
very unusual for most people.
There's a few months off in between
fights in a lot of that is because you
get beat up and you got to relax and
rest and,
and heal up.
You know,
if you have any injuries,
they have to be fixed.
Some guys break their hands,
you know,
some guys pull ligaments,
they have to get operations.
You know,
Shogun just got an operation on his
knee.
Can imagine if they did that like in
Vegas or something.
I think a better bar solution when the
UFC has this gigantic library of 116
events,
the best idea is to serve good food,
have a cool bar,
and have the UFC plans data,
all these different fucking,
um,
television steak bar with UFC
everywhere.
And then when,
during the live shows they have like
huge movie theater.
Yes.
During or they have it on every goddamn
10 in the room during a live show.
They have it on every Goddamn TV in the
room and you have to pay 20 bucks to get
in or whatever it is.
And call it town.
They would clean the fuck up one of the
UFC bar because really it would be.
It's really,
there's a cool thing about watching it
live.
I love watching fights live because it's
crazy and you're right there when it's
going down.
It's really nothing.
That experience is nothing like anything
you've ever had before.
If your seats are good,
but if your seats aren't that good,
you know,
if you're in the bleachers,
it's kind of cool being there still,
but it's pretty fucking bad ass to go to
a place with a bunch of other people and
watch it on TV.
You know,
like having a ufc bar where people know
if you can't afford to go to Vegas,
you know you're living in another city.
Everybody,
all your friends are going to go to the
UFC bar and watch the fight.
Totally.
I think it would be for mma fans alone
and everything.
I think Dana could have like its own
little mini Davis desserts,
peroxide or status.
Think very shallow.
Grave again is a Ravioli.
Do Revenue.
Why do I have Ravioli?
That would work?
That would work,
but having live fights,
I don't think that would work.
I think there'll be a little too much.
Yeah,
but no,
seriously.
I'm sure that's doing good too.
I don't know.
I don't really think about it pretty
crazy.
Some dude,
a facebook me from a UFC champion was
like,
I'm the manager of.
You have to be driven by fear.
We're in town in a workout
buddy.
I think that sounds like a great idea.
Fucking twosome squats at UFC gym.
Take a Goddamn Tae Bo class.
Right?
Wonder what kind of classes are going to
have.
They're gonna.
What kind of liability do you have if
you let dudes actually beat the shit out
of each other.
I know because if you have sparring,
the bottom line is you're not going
through extensive medicals when you have
sparring.
Like when dudes spar and kickboxing
classes.
I've never taken a blood test,
have never taken a fucking cat scan.
I've never never taken shit,
but that's like any workout,
any jim has just sign here.
We're not responsible.
Good Dude.
You don't even sign anything at boxing
gyms.
Most of them you don't say shit.
The Ham,
the places I've worked on them,
they'll just slap gloves on you and you
climb in the ring with another dude that
you don't even know and you say,
you know,
okay,
so you know,
just go easy,
go easy.
Let me see what you can do.
And you're fucking throwing punches with
some dude that you don't even know and
you know,
who knows?
Most of the time dudes are cool,
but every now and then dudes will try to
take your head off.
They don't know.
He might have an aneurysm just ready to
pop right behind your eyeball and he
touches you in a chin.
Your legs go,
you fall,
you hit your head on the back of the mat
and that thing burst and just fills your
eyeballs with blood and you fucking die
right there.
That's possible.
I need to go to.
When I went to get my eyes checked a
while back,
they were like,
there was something in the back of your
eye.
It's probably nothing but you should
take her to a doctor.
And I'm like,
ah,
Oh,
you've got a brain tumor.
That was like 10 years ago though.
I wouldn't know it right now to smoke a
lot of weed and working on it.
A lot of vegetables,
15 pounds to get drink my Kombucha to.
You've lost 15 pounds over the course of
how long?
Since the 18th of June.
That's.
That's a lot of wait,
how the fuck you losing that much weight
crack cigarettes,
hookers.
Now a modified weight watchers,
the weight watchers diet,
which is modified,
meaning you take in less calories.
A weight watchers is.
You have this many points you use them
based on is the food,
like an orange is two points,
you know as sandwiches,
six points,
whatever.
So what I've been doing is doing the
weight watchers diet but only eating
zero to one point shit.
So mostly vegetables.
Most of you do.
You eat little small meals to keep your
metabolism.
They eat small meals throughout the day.
That's what it's all like one point zero
point shit and I'm not going anywhere
close to my allotted 35 points a day.
I'm probably doing seven,
seven points a day.
You're like a little checks.
Just like chicken.
He loves your God damn check Bro.
You're like Lindsay Lohan starving
yourself to death.
Totally.
It's great.
No,
but I'm making sure I'm getting all the
nutrients and proteins and all that
stuff.
Since I've done Brian just for Fyi since
I've known why is your phone on?
That's not me or alerts.
You're getting alerts since I've known
Brian.
He's done this like five times where it
got heavy and then he got skinny.
You got heavy guy.
Eating is one of the safest ways to
create your life.
Like he went from.
You were up at like,
how was the heaviest you wherever at
2:43
to 43 and by the way he's.
How tall are you?
Five,
eight,
five,
2:43.
That's giant.
He was a fat guy like his legs used to
touch together in the middle,
get a weird,
crazy pants.
His pants were always way too long
because his waist and his boss were way
too big for that long,
so they had.
He had all his pants were like always
like shuffling and then this guy got
dumped by his girlfriend and fiance,
fiance,
sorry.
It was much more devastating than just a
girlfriend,
right?
Seven years.
They were together for a long time.
It was very devastating and he went on a
God damn weight watcher,
a elliptical machine,
rampage.
And over the course of how long?
Three months,
you lost like 70 pounds.
I was,
I'm 63 was the lowest I got.
Then I decided to snows in three months.
Yeah,
that's,
that's so unhealthy.
So unhealthy dude.
You basically starved yourself.
Do you have pictures of yourself when
you were asking?
Do you have anything that would shock
the,
uh,
the people at home?
Yeah,
I do actually have something ready to
hold that up so I can take a look at
that because it was really strange.
He,
it turns out Brian has a weird head.
We just don't know because it's always
like,
it's always embraced in a,
in a role of soft tissue and you don't
get to see the true shape of his head.
But when you just see skinny Brian
Skinny,
Brian is a strange dude.
I don't even know what nationality he
is.
He looks like he's a fucking alien.
I'll find it.
Where's Kenny?
Brian?
We've got to do is we've got to make
your neck a buildup.
This to match your head is very
important.
You know,
you can have a big head as long as you
have a big neck to support that big
head.
You got a big heads on and you don't
have a big neck and that shit look
strange.
Well,
that's because that's because your head
is used to the be your body being
gigantic.
So what you gotta do is you gotTa build
your neck up.
You know,
that's one of the most popular things in
Hollywood though,
for actors to have exercises.
They want you to have a big head.
What is that about A.
I don't know.
It's a thing where maybe it's a more
more brains,
but it can't be true because I know some
people would pick heads or stupid as,
fuck.
Here's a picture of me holding my old
pants up.
Wow.
Well,
this is not helping the people at home.
Now I may find a better one and I'll put
it to my twitter later today.
Well,
when you do,
I'll retweet it because I know people
are fucking excited to see what you look
like.
When you look strange.
There's one picture I have that's just
so scary.
What was interesting is when you became,
went from being a fat guy to a skinny
guy,
you also found out that you're
attractive and you started getting
girls.
Girls were liking you.
Man was like,
you know,
like shit should be into Brian.
And Brian was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Look at this slide.
Well then what happens?
Then I settle in and then he'd get a
girlfriend,
girlfriend.
I gained it all back.
Never gained it all back.
No,
I didn't.
I'm probably one on one 95 right now.
One 95.
So at least you're still 40.
Whatever pounds right away from what you
were.
Right.
I don't want to get back to one 65.
That was way too.
I looked like I had aids.
No,
you didn't like what you're supposed to
look like.
Dude did just so used to sit yourself
gigantic.
You did not look like you had aids,
I swear.
Never looks like scary skinny.
You never did.
It looked weird because like all of a
sudden you were like tiny person.
You know?
That's you.
That's ridiculous.
I thought that looks like a healthy
person.
Right?
I hate to say that it looks like a
healthy person.
Your problem is your head's too big for
your body.
You got to start working out.
If you started working out to it,
you'd be a sexy bitch right there.
You're looking sexy as fuck.
Yeah.
There was a dude that I know that has
the tiniest head and it always trips me
out whenever I talked to him.
He has that backwards.
He has a tiniest head.
Every is a very small head and all I can
think of when I'm next to him was would
it be like to punch him in his little
tiny head?
I don't want to do it.
I would never do it,
but I just think man,
if you punch this guy and not even me,
like if a person did punch this guy in
his tiny little head,
like you could just crush his head.
He's got a bird head.
It's weird.
I'd rather,
I'd rather have a way big to head with
big two way big too.
Filled with smarts.
My fucking stupid head is smart as fuck.
So,
um,
your,
that's another skinny photo frame these
up on twitter.
I'm telling you,
dude,
that looks healthy.
I think I look like,
I think I look like gay lesbian,
right?
Brian,
that's what you look like.
Goddammit.
You're gay,
lesbian underneath it all.
That's what you look like when you're
thin.
That's a layer.
But I don't want to be a gay lesbian,
but how come you,
how come you can't stay the same?
What don't you like monitor your weight
and you see it go up.
And what do you do?
What's the process when you see it going
up?
What keeps you from just recognizing
that and cutting back on your food?
Well,
it's not even a cut back on food.
It's,
it's,
I have the metabolism of a small goat
where I like goats or skinny as fuck.
Dude,
you're talking about the lean.
That's a terrible example.
I met it backwards.
You have the metabolism of fat person.
Yeah,
I mean I fucking eat like two pieces of
pizza again.
So if you just gave up and just we're a
sedentary fuck and had a normal nine to
five job.
We ain't shit at the office and eat shit
for launch and then you came home and
you were too tired to work and you ate
and then watch TV.
You just be a giant fat.
Huge.
I'd be crazy huge.
I wonder how many grandmother was like
600 pounds on my dad's side.
Really?
Yeah.
She was humongous.
Diabetes.
Everything that's scary.
And my dad's side.
Yeah.
I wonder how many dudes who are like
that have like a hormonal imbalance or a
thyroid imbalance or something that
could be correct.
Well,
it's.
So I got mine checked and supposedly
fine.
Whatever.
That's fine,
but I didn't check your testosterone.
Now I don't know.
I saw this or not.
So I was listening to Sirius satellite
radio the other day and one of the
things that we're saying about guys who
gained a lot of weight,
there's a lot of times it's just some
sort of a,
a hormone imbalance and that it's a
maybe a testosterone and balance like a
cure it with like some cream.
Yeah.
But when I just get more hairier
I don't need that anymore and have some
fucking energy and,
and not,
not become fat.
Shouldn't get that checked honestly,
because I bet you I'm fucking know you
tired all the time.
Oh,
I'm tired from when I wake.
I wake up in the morning,
I'm tired.
Guaranteed.
And especially because you don't do
anything that forces your body to
produce it.
You're not involved in any heavy lifting
or anything,
you know?
I think that's one of the most important
things when you're maintaining your
health,
as you get older,
you have to do strength training,
you have to do cpr training that makes
your body constantly regenerate tissue.
Keep your glands pumping.
When I wake up,
I really feel tired.
Like I,
I never would have woken up and be like,
wow,
I might have sleep apnea too.
I probably had that.
You snore,
chicks tell you snore.
Yeah.
Do you ever like gagging or sleep or
don't do that?
Well,
you should get tested,
man.
I got a new mouthpiece that I started
wearing,
you know,
because I got diagnosed with sleep apnea
a few years ago.
And one doctor created this mouthpiece,
it's got Dr Caribbean and Tarzana.
They created some a mouthpiece that
keeps your tongue down.
And the problem is I have a big tongue
and my neck is big from working out all
the time and my whole that I have in the
back of my throat,
it's not so big.
And so when I lie down,
like tongue falls back as I relaxed and
covers over the fucking hole and I gag
and cough.
Like a lot of times it's fat people,
fat people have it,
but athletes have it a lot to anybody
who has a,
like a big neck.
If you have a big tongue it's probably
going to happen to you.
So this mouthpiece kind of keeps your
tongue down.
Well,
he just invented a new one.
I just started using this new one.
Dude.
It's incredible.
I wake up,
I feel so fucking rested.
Mrs Rogan says I don't snore at all
anymore and I feel so much better than
my dreams are super vivid man.
My dreams are really intense.
They're really like very,
very lifelike to the point where
sometimes my alarm goes off in mid dream
and I'm like,
wow,
that was a dream because it's not even,
they're not even like crazy dreams.
Their dreams,
like life dreams.
It's like,
you know,
it's very strange.
They don't have a dream like feel to
them.
They feel like I,
I dropped another level below in my,
my,
my depth of my sleeping,
you know?
And so I'm having these,
um,
uh,
maybe I'm reaching a rem level that I
wasn't reaching before because I was
snoring all the time.
He would choke and I have a sleep apnea
problem because even the mouthpiece
didn't totally cure it.
It's,
it definitely made it better.
Right.
But I still snowboard this new one.
I don't snore at all.
Is that a picture of you and Jenna
Jameson for when she waits,
but when we were in Arizona.
So,
uh,
what's the goal now?
You're at one 95.
And what's your goal?
Trying to get to win 65.
You should get your hormones checked
out.
Son might have problems,
you know,
they can once you can do things to cure
it,
but one of the things that that works is
squats,
and heavy lifting makes your body
produce more testosterone,
makes your body produce more growth
hormone is very good for you,
but you've got to not be pushy.
You don't actually do them.
Yeah.
You don't seem like the type of dude
that's really into it just seemed like
the,
the energy I per day is so small that to
me,
you looked at it like I feel like I am.
I'm barely trying nurses and I'm barely
trying not to go back to sleep.
Jam to you.
I need to get yourself checked out.
Yeah.
What if you have a real issue?
But if I've had it,
it's been.
I've had it my whole life.
If I've had it,
what do you think?
I don't know what fucking damn kids get
off my lawn.
We haven't looked at the photo,
the,
uh,
the questions on,
on twitter and forever.
Oh,
here's the other thing that I did last
week that I forgot.
Uh,
I actually gave my phone number out on
twitter,
what's going on with that fucked up
royally.
I gave my phone number out,
I gave it to Doug Benson because doug
was going to come to vegas this weekend
and he wanted to come hang out with us
at the House of Blues and I said,
yeah man.
I said I can even get into the UFC.
Here's my,
here's my phone number,
call me.
And I put it in the main twitter box
instead of the direct message box.
I thought I was saying to direct
message.
So I tweeted my fucking number two,
the whole world.
So I was like,
God damn it.
And then it just started vibrating and
five breeding and the calls were just
coming in like they did never stopped.
It was like one after the other,
you know when you have.
I've got 130 something thousand twitter
friends and who knows how many,
10,
maybe 10,000.
Might've seen it.
I tried to delete it but it was too
late.
It was out there.
And so then as I was driving to the
verizon store to go change my number,
I just start answering phone calls.
Like,
what's up,
man?
Yeah man,
what's going on?
My Way?
The verizon store,
I'm turning in my phone.
I have to,
I would answer it here for you guys and
show you.
But uh,
I mean I have a rise in the verizon
doesn't work here where I live,
you know,
uh,
but I did it all.
We eat it as a family act.
Very nice that you could have told all
those more onto called you and ruined
your phone number.
You could have just posted all those
online and fuck them,
you know.
But you were nice about it.
You take the high road.
She,
well,
what are they doing?
They're just,
look,
I fucked up.
It's out there,
right?
You're not going to take it away.
It's not like everyone's going to be so
cool that no one's going to call you on
that.
That'd be great to have.
Everyone was cool because some of the
people just wanted to call to say hi,
why not?
If you were 18 years old and you were a
fan of some dude and all the sudden he's
got his phone number online and you call
him and he actually answers like,
Holy Shit,
but that's most of the calls.
Most of the calls were people saying,
Holy Shit,
and they were all cool.
What did you go about fate or losing?
They're just never going to bring them
in now.
And all these conversations about
fucking out of conversations about
comedy.
I conversations about about mma.
I had a bunch of different conversations
but all kinds of shit and I was like,
I'm going to keep this phone,
fuck it.
So I kept it as a fan line.
You want to call it?
I really do answer it.
Not all the time,
but I pick it up every now and then.
Eight,
one,
eight,
five,
one,
seven,
two,
four.
That's my phone number.
That's my fam line.
Now I said that was a real number.
I thought that'd be kind of cooler to,
to actually give out the real number
instead of getting another number and
making it my fan line.
It's like actually kind of cool that you
actually have my real number.
I mean that's like my,
my legit number that I've had for a
decade.
Right.
So that's my number eight and that's the
deal.
This weekend I'm going to be at the
Ontario Improv with the one and only
Joey Coco Diaz and that's going to be a
lot of fun.
Ontario is a bad ass club.
It's selling out quickly.
So,
um,
if you want to get in,
I know a lot of people got shut out in
Irvine.
I talked to a lot of people that were
disappointed and I'm sorry I didn't get
in,
but you know,
these clubs they only see like 300
people.
So if you,
if you want to come to a show,
especially like the Friday's shows and
the Saturday shows Sunday sometimes a
little easier because you've got less
people out doing things.
But Friday and Saturday those was
fucking tickets sell quick.
Irvine was awesome.
Irvine last week and every show sold
out.
Every show was cool.
People were cool as fuck.
It was awesome.
And then house of Blues was awesome too.
Although I did get a tad too drunk just
to touch what happened.
Unshocked over the line.
What happened bad because I didn't see
nothing.
It was nothing bad.
The show was great but I definitely got
too drunk and I,
I told the second half of a joke twice,
but as,
because I didn't tell the first half of
it right the first time.
So I tried to like Redo it and then I
and then I realized as I was saying that
I was like,
I already said this isn't that,
does that to here,
do you guys.
But I just admit it,
you admit it and like I immediately just
stopped and admitted it and just said
what happened and Eddie Eddie's going to
pointed out and I go,
yeah,
I know,
but I did it because I fucked up this
part of it.
Right.
It's not a good enough answer.
It's the answer.
It really is.
I was drunk.
That's the answer.
I mean,
I'm saying what I did wrong,
but the only reason why I did it again
because I was drunk,
I just,
I didn't have anything to eat and I had
like three shots in a row on stage,
which is two shots too many,
but still it was still fun.
Fucking fuck fun.
Like really happy crowd.
They were cool.
Sam Tripoli was hilarious.
Sam was awesome.
He crushed it.
It was really good at that place.
Could go either way.
Sometimes UFC nights that places,
you know,
house of Blues.
It's just a madhouse.
He kissed it,
we fixed it,
we fixed it when we got rid of the
standing.
Only that changed the vibe of it so much
because people are uncomfortable before
and you felt that uncomfort from them
because the fact that they had a stand
and watch a show and I made a lot more
money than on those shows,
but I don't care.
I don't want people to stand up.
I think it sucks when we saw stand up
when we saw stan hope rather than shit
cured me.
No more standup shows.
I'll never make someone pay to see me.
Stand up ever again and we fucked up and
Memphis,
joey and I did a show in Memphis and it
had to be stand up because it was a
really tiny place and it was a standard,
would only see like 100 people and all
of these people were standing by the
bar,
so half the crowd was standing and they
were all talking at full voice,
like bar voice,
like no one was like paying attention to
the show.
When Joey went onstage,
no one was like maybe 10 percent of the
people in the bar weren't talking.
It was just a low rumble and then you
know,
it was like,
okay,
this is the final Straw.
Never have a standing room show ever.
It's not fun to watch fan.
You know,
the part of what is good about a shell
as you can kick back and relax,
where we'll be awesome is if they every
fucking place you went had real
comfortable seats.
You know,
if you could sit on a couch like this,
if that's how you watched a every comedy
show,
you know,
kicking back and chilling on a couch,
how fucking it would be way funnier
because you'd be feeling relaxed.
She have no tension.
It's like you're,
you're more likely to laugh at shit when
you're standing.
Your fucking feet hurt.
That sucks.
First Person I ever heard say that was
Jimmy Norton and are Jimmy talking about
it?
There was um,
promoting one of his shows and uh,
it was talking about,
you know,
people were calling in and saying that
they heard there was standing tickets in
the back.
And Jimmy was like,
no,
it's going to be,
this was my show is a standing show.
And I was like,
wow.
He's like real adamant about that,
but I didn't think it was that big of a
deal.
I'm like,
well,
maybe he's just,
you know,
he's more rigid with his style or
something and he wants to make it like
that.
But then I,
you know,
I realized that that's the right thing
to do.
Those standing shows,
they'll stand hope shows.
I mean,
they're fun and everything,
but it's not as fun.
Yeah.
To me,
I don't know if it's my age or what it
the whole time I'm just focusing on the
pain of my standing.
Like how uncomfortable it wasn't a huge
thing,
man.
I didn't like standing up with a
concrete floor when I was 10.
No,
it doesn't feel good.
When I worked at gateway,
had to do it eight hours and weren't
allowed to sit down.
You know,
the day that you would find like the
thickest shoes and then you put like the
best like inserts.
It's not good for you.
It's not,
you know,
your body's supposed to
be moving around too because that's what
I do.
Stand up and I'm on stage for an hour
and a half or whatever.
I'm on four.
It doesn't.
I've never hurt.
I feel fine.
I'll get off on feel.
I feel energized,
but standing in one place and not moving
at all for an hour and a half.
That sucks.
That's terrible.
You know,
you're,
you're carrying your weight.
You know,
you don't even think about it,
but you're not even like moving.
You don't even get blood flowing through
it and you're right next to other people
so you can't like stretch your arms out
and move your body and touch your toes
and shit and unwind.
Like if you don't do that,
man,
your body feels like shit.
Think it's very important for.
That's one of the reasons why I don't
like doing comedy too much in bars
anymore.
I don't like I'll do it every now and
then just for a goof.
Just to experience something different.
You'd get a different taste of comedy,
you know,
do like a little,
a shitty little Hollywood gigs every now
and again.
But I think it's very important that the
right atmosphere,
it has to be set.
You know,
the same atmosphere that is good for
music.
It's not the same atmosphere of is good
for comedy.
You know,
your music.
You could go up and people could be
talking to like,
how's everybody doing out there?
And then you play your song,
man,
you don't.
You don't require their attention 100
percent there.
They're complete interaction.
You don't require that.
You don't require a response,
a definite response from them.
Comedy though,
it's tricky,
very tricky.
Setting up the atmosphere.
So tricky.
That's why it's important to go on the
road would dudes who I think are funny.
I always go on the road with friends.
It's so important.
The worst thing you could ever do is go
on the road and a guy opens for you and
the guy fucking sucks.
He doesn't just suck.
He likes sucks.
Like aggressively and like it's like bad
material and it's badly done and totally
different crowd that you would have,
you know,
that he would have normally to.
Yeah,
most of them would never have a crowd at
all.
The really bad ones.
Yeah.
And I've been one of those really bad
ones by the way.
I'm not shitting on them.
I mean it's part of the development
process in writing this book that I'm
writing about a lot of my early comedy
days,
so making me rehash old bombing stories
that I forgot of like terrible fucking
disastrous tales of the road and they're
fucking crazy,
you know,
but a lot of it was just because I
sucked.
I was just terrible.
I didn't know how to relax back then.
I didn't know how to do comedy yet.
I was really just feeling it out,
which is fine and good,
you know,
and it's a thing you have to go through,
but I don't want people going through it
before I get up onstage because if they
do it right before you,
it's like,
it taints the whole room.
So if someone just came on stage and
just shit into their minds,
you know,
and then you're forced to like clean
everything up and start from scratch.
You have to do damage control,
you know?
Yeah.
So weird.
It a comic.
I know he's,
I think 20 years old and uh,
he's just the nicest guy,
little kid ever,
you know,
he's always,
he's always asking for advice too,
like Ari and me and stuff like that.
It's just a really nice guy and he just
can't tell him how,
just how nice this guy is.
Did you fuck him?
Well,
he just said that.
He told me the other day that he's going
to be like,
lead role in like a real movie now,
and he's going to go from this nice
little open mic young kid.
Now he's going to be like,
lead role in a movie and it's just,
it's a big movie as well.
I think it's a,
it's.
I think it's a big movie.
It's like,
it's about what it is.
It's supposed to be like a cloverfield,
but it's um,
it's a like at a party with like
generation x guys or whatever.
Generally it becomes a monster movie.
How it's recorded.
Like it's like,
what about cell phones,
cell phones and stuff like that.
Man,
I'm not buying them anymore.
I
bought that shit with like the um,
I thought it was kind of interesting.
The Blair witch project,
how they did that.
I thought that was a good movie.
I mean,
it was really for what it was when we
saw the Blair witch project,
the first time I saw him was we were in
Houston and Chris go,
Chris Mcguire and I were working at,
uh,
the laptop and the,
this was way back in the day whenever it
came out.
And this dude who worked at the movie
theater across the street came to the
show and after the show we're all
hanging out and smoking weed.
And the dude goes,
Hey,
do you guys want to go watch the Blair
witch project right now?
We can all watch it.
Like,
we'll set it up.
I got the keys,
we'll turn it on.
I'm like,
get the fuck Outta here.
You serious?
He's like,
yeah.
So we,
it was like a midnight show.
Okay.
So we went over there 2:00
in the morning and this dude had the
keys unlock the place.
We got popcorn and shit.
And it was him,
the dude he,
he worked there.
A couple other people that work with
him,
like a guy and a girl and me and Chris
Mcguire says five of us.
We watched the Blair witch project and
it was bad ass was the perfect way to
was.
It freaked me the second time I watched
it,
it was terrible network.
Not only did it not work,
there was some dude who brought his baby
and this fucking Mexican dude and his
baby was making all this noise who's
like to,
you know,
and you know,
so a bunch of people like shushed,
um,
and he got aggressive with the people,
fuck you bitch,
don't fucking touch me bitch.
And I was like,
oh,
okay,
now I have to fucking think about this
guy and his fucking inconsiderate ways
and he's got a baby and people trying to
shush them and he's,
you know,
fucking yelling at them obscenity and
threatening them,
I'll fucking kick your ass bitch.
And that kind of shit.
And so now you got to think about him
for the fucking movie or.
So it was a bad experience
as you know,
I don't really like going to movies
anymore.
So roll the dice.
Yeah,
I mean I,
especially when nowadays it's like I can
get a blue ray,
I can,
I can wait six months and that the
experience at my house now is better
than I think going movie.
Yeah.
If you have a nice good sized TV and you
know,
you're,
you've got a good size sound system,
plastic,
you don't have to worry.
I can smoke weed.
Yeah,
you can have whatever food you want.
You can have a comfortable couch to
watch it on.
It's a way better experience,
but people like the event of being out
there with other people,
you know,
people like.
That's one of the things that people
like about a concert Fuckin Ozzy Osborne
was playing just to you and it was just
you and ozzy alone with his band in the
room.
You probably wouldn't even want to be
there.
You know,
it'd be like maybe listen to a song or
two and be like,
this is crazy.
He's looking me in the eyes and singing
fucking,
you know,
you'd have to look at you.
You're the only one there,
but if you're one of 15,000
in an arena then it's cool.
Then it's fun.
That's crazy.
But I think movie theaters need to
reboot,
man.
I,
I think they need to stop going,
hey,
we're charging you $14 for tickets.
$8 for a popcorn.
$5 for a pop.
I think they need to kind of fuck that.
You have to pay that much just to watch
it.
Whereas if you want to own it,
it's like 30 bucks and a few months.
Not even that.
You can get at best buy for 1499 on DVD,
you know,
12,
99.
Not Blue Ray though,
right?
Blu Ray.
30 bucks.
Sometimes opening week or first week
they'll have it on sale for like a 17.
Yeah.
If you watch something blue,
right.
It's so much better.
So much more comfortable watching shit
at home.
This.
I watched the wolf man the other day
again.
Yeah,
I watched it again.
I don't even like it.
It's terrible movie,
but I think it's dope when it's.
When it's at home,
what's at home?
I like it.
It's not bad.
My son in the movie theater,
I'm like,
I paid for this fucking stupid movie.
This movie's retarded.
What do I say?
That was pretty good.
Oh,
the crazies crazy dude.
The craziest as good goddamn horror
movie.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't want to tell you the premise
because I didn't know a thing about it.
I'll give you the blue rag.
I got it up here.
Oh,
cool.
I didn't know a thing about it.
I knew nothing,
but someone had said this is a really
scary movie.
Someone twitted it.
So.
Ah Mate,
check it out because I don't know.
I love what I don't know anything about
movie.
I didn't know nothing.
I didn't.
I hadn't seen a single preview.
I saw a photo with a guy with a
pitchfork.
That's it.
That's all I know.
So I'm like,
okay.
Some crazy shit.
Obviously guys killing people with a
pitchfork,
right.
Great movie.
I mean not the best movie in the world,
but a good goddamn horror movie.
Good solid.
Like Holy Shit.
Horror movie.
And then I'm like,
why wasn't this movie popular?
Well,
why didn't this movie go somewhere in
the movie theater?
It's pretty fucking good.
I didn't hear a thing about it.
Did you hear anything about it?
Uh,
I just remember they advertise or the
advertising,
how they advertised it.
The last airbender I have not seen it.
You know why?
Because you're not fooling me again.
You fuck em night Shama Lama.
Ding Dong your movies.
I terrible.
I think it was done.
I think half the fucker happy Internet
internet sat there when he had zero
percent on rotten tomatoes.
I was like,
yes.
This is hilarious.
I know he has zero percent on rotten
tomatoes for a long time.
Like six or seven or something.
Yeah,
he's got a few percent now.
There's a few fools out there or some
staff members from unite.
Shama Lama.
Ding dongs fucking what?
What makes me even more angry is the
fact that the opposite is happening with
toy story three,
because that's the movie.
I don't care if you're the most angriest
person who road.
You sit there and you will go at least.
Yeah.
That was a good movie.
You know?
That was those pixar movies are always
good,
man.
They were so good at it.
One bad one,
I think there was one or two bad ones
and it's just like,
really I want to meet these people and
go,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like are you really that angry of a
person or are you somebody from a
different movie studio just being a
Dick,
you know,
because there's a lot of espionage and
fucking double crossing online for sure.
A lot of positive comments as well by
paid shills,
you know,
people have accused the UFC of doing
that all the time on the underground.
People were saying,
how many of you guys are paid UFC
Scheel's as far as I know there are
none,
but there might be.
I might just not know about them.
It might very well be that they hire
people to get online.
I mean it's effective marketing.
If you think about it,
you get online,
you hype up a fight,
you start talking,
you instigate comments,
you know.
Do you think that,
you know,
Shane would have been knocked out by
Brett Rogers in or that there would have
been knocked out by Brett Rogers?
Sometimes it is.
I know it is.
I know,
but I know in the pride days they used
to do that.
There's just a lot of people also.
That's all they think that is true,
but,
but as far as like a,
as far as like putting together threads
and pushing real positive threads and
talking about how excited you are for
something,
it's a good move.
You know,
it was a smart move,
you know,
if you get a good thread together,
I think Amazon reviews or that.
Yeah.
Well I pay attention to Amazon's refuse.
That half of it could be total bullshit.
Yeah.
I even try to read it to say,
okay,
does this sound like something like a
publicist made or the company made?
No one can stop you from doing that.
You could review the shit out of your
own stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
I've never done that with anything I've
ever done.
I've never done that.
But um,
I was pleasantly surprised at how cool
fucking comments I got on the itunes
thing.
I thought when I was going over the
podcast,
I'm like,
this is going to be a bunch of Douche
bags that don't want to hear us yapping
about things because this is kind of a
free form podcasts.
A lot of times we talk about the same
subjects we've talked about before,
but they're relevant to the current
conversation.
I can't.
I got to assume that each one of these
to our things is its own thing and try
not to repeat things as much as
possible,
but.
And it's also just hard to remember what
was 28 times two.
How many hours is that of training?
I also think that we get into subjects a
lot deeper than you can if you just do
it an hour podcast,
you know,
I'd like to our podcast format,
but I think there's something about like
really intense conversations or you
know,
we have these cool conversations.
You have to let them kind of take their
fucking path,
you know?
And sometimes it's like,
well this is it.
We're just going to stop it now.
But you know,
just more shit to be talked about,
you know,
but so many fucking people who said,
things on the itunes,
we're,
we're cool.
There's a bunch of complaints about the
sound,
which we did have problems with the
sound but we fixed all that shit.
And if you think it's too low,
stop listening in on your iphone speaker
phone.
It's low for everything.
Brian's very upset with this.
Listen guys said into how low it was.
And so today I recorded myself going on
like Adam Carolla as you know,
all the couple of them and then.
And then ours got allowed us.
This is good now we mean and I think
this is the right way to do it too
because I've heard things where people
talk on lab mix and it's not quite as
loud or clear.
Yeah.
I think the reason why radio stations
use these kind of mix and standup comedy
uses this kind of mix and this is,
this is the right shit to use.
So this is the way we're going to keep
it.
As far as like putting up this green
screen,
I kind of gave up on that shit.
I think it's distracting.
I might put up a,
um,
a banner or something,
maybe put up a big flat screen and have
a constantly changing logo.
Make you could put together some Nettie
video and will be playing in the
background.
Do you think could move,
just show ideas on a toilet.
But I think I've given up on the idea of
us being in space looking liquor,
cable access show 'em.
The fleshlight is our only sponsor.
And the lawyer said before that if it
wasn't a sponsor,
I would still tell you to use it.
Things the fucking bomb diggity me too.
It's awesome.
Um,
gigs this weekend.
I will be at the Ontario Improv Friday,
Saturday and Sunday with Joey Diaz.
Uh,
as you said,
tickets are selling quick,
so if you want to come,
come the next time I'll be.
If you're in La and you want to go
somewhere closer.
I am a at the universal city.
John Lovitz has a comedy club up there
that John Lovitz comedy club and that's
next Saturday.
It's like the 17th or some shit,
something like that to show next
Saturday,
two shows.
I've never been there before.
I heard it's good and Jon Lovitz is a
nice guy.
Like that guy.
I love that shopping center.
I had her,
that whole universal place.
I love that place.
Yeah,
that's a cool place I think being at
Disney road.
So,
uh,
that's it.
Ladies and gentlemen for this week.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We appreciate it.
The fuck out of it as always,
and a much respect.
Much love and we will see you all next
week.
Same Bat time,
same bat.
Not.
This is not even the same time.
It was next week.
We're going to keep doing it though.
We will not stop.
We will not end.
And we do this all because of your
support because the fact that you guys
are enjoying it and I appreciate the
fuck out of it.
Thank you very much.
I love you bitches.